Thank you.
You sugar over there.
No sugar.
We have a thing called Stevia natural.
Whereas it Ryan,
we're on
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
A boy,
Sam triple.
He got his first flashlight today in his moy.
Excited though Christmas up in here.
It is like Chris don't put too much of that stuff and that strong.
It's not sugar.
It's super healthy though,
man.
Super Healthy.
San Aaa first flashlight ever today will be Christening it folks.
You know,
it's a silly product and people go,
well,
why do you have the flashlight sponsoring your podcast?
Like,
what's up with that?
Like it's Kinda,
it's Kinda like why wouldn't you?
Well,
because I think people think that there's something silly and there's something
where people are not going to take you seriously,
you know,
you're admitting to fucking some fake vagina,
you know?
But,
but,
but here's the thing,
I do shows and I have like a sex toy company name,
a fun factory does my live shows with me and there they had the cadillacs of FEC
and vibrators and girls go crazy over that issue.
He ever is.
Definitely a vibrator.
Girls are allowed to get vibrators.
Dudes are not allowed to have it before.
Like something that smelled like a raft pop.
Yeah.
Those things are useless.
When fleshlight came along,
there was nothing else.
It's fucking good dude.
It's good.
I,
uh,
have used it several times.
It's way better than beating off.
And that's like a weird thing to admit.
People don't admit that they masturbate.
My name is Joe Rogan and I masturbate.
So this podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight because it's fucking solid
product,
man.
Alright.
Forget about all the what?
When I first moved down here,
I didn't masturbate or talk about masturbation to anybody.
You're the first person from Ohio.
You're the first person that I remember.
You were always like talking about it.
I'm like,
I should talk about it.
And I remember I started talking about masturbating and then now it's just like,
I do it every day.
There are definitely some suppress people there.
You know?
How about everywhere,
man,
all over the country.
You know when you're just hanging out with comedians now anyway,
if you go to Joe Rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight,
that was an extended commercial was great commercial about it because I've taken
shit about this product.
People think it's ridiculous.
I used it the other day.
It's a good product.
God dammit.
There's literally given with it.
I don't.
I think people will.
Some people are not going to want to Zeus.
You associated with the flashlight.
Good.
Those eggshells.
Who knows?
I don't get that are out there and they're.
They're the people that want to stop occupy Wall Street.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net and click on the link and enter in the code and name
Rogan,
and you will get 15 percent off the number one sex toy furman.
Sam Tripoli is also going to get some Alpha brain today.
I'm very excited about.
We're also sponsored by Alpha brain.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com,
o n n I t a,
we have a bunch of products now.
We have Alpha brain and then we have this new,
uh,
new mood knew mood is a five htp supplement,
which,
uh,
I found out about that shift from Neal Brennan,
but there's a bunch of different things that you can do.
They're called nootropics to tweak your mind.
And uh,
this Alpha brain thing has not been without controversy.
I have to be honest.
There's people who love it.
And then there's people who say it's a placebo.
It doesn't do shit.
I mean,
people have been taking these particular nutrients like Coleen and a bunch of
different other ones were like,
they're referred to as nootropics.
They've been taking them for years.
And the idea behind it is that it just makes you think a little clearer.
It's not this fucking Bradley Cooper,
limitless shit.
It's not going to make you smart if you're dumb.
But I liked the way it affects me.
I take two every morning with water and I believe in it.
And you know,
there's um,
there's a lot of controversy about it though.
There's controversy about the science behind it and we are doing the best to
clear up all that stuff.
We're going to release a new document tonight.
I think it might already be up there on on it for people who are concerned about
the amount of l Dopa in it from a being the velvet bean,
actually,
it's an extract of food extract.
The idea behind all of this is that I think the body works better when it's
supplemented with nutrients with a lot of nutrients.
I think you work better when you take fish oil.
There's a lot of controversy behind that.
I think your body works,
but I know my joints work better when I take fish oil for sure.
No question about it because I do a lot of really hard training.
I do Jujitsu and lift weights and when I don't take fish oil,
I notice a difference in how my joints feel.
Well,
you're fine tunes and fine tuned instrument and uh,
I take vitamins,
I take multivitamins and take them coital mineral drink everyday.
I do a lot of different drink,
a lot of fresh squeezed juices.
I'm very concerned with keeping my body running at a,
at a,
at a good place,
you know,
keeping my body running healthy and well fulfilled.
I always want to make sure I get the right shit in it.
And when I take this stuff and I take this alphabet,
I can definitely notice a difference.
This is like,
I don't know if everybody can and I don't know,
maybe some people are just negative.
I don't know,
maybe some people's bodies are just different because it's weird.
You get to the variations are people love it.
It's changed like mayhem.
Miller is fucking in love with this stuff.
Do you think it's people that are just not fine tuned to them themselves?
He could because there's another,
there's another product that we're selling that uh,
you know,
it took me a while to be sold on.
It's based on the quarter steps mushroom,
it's called shroom tech and with a quarter zips mushroom is a mushroom that
enhances your body's ability to utilize oxygen and Olympic athletes.
And China used it and won a bunch of metals.
And um,
this,
this mushroom is we've known for free like many,
many hundreds of years that people in Tibet and people in high high altitudes
will eat certain routes and certain plants to make them feel better,
like,
you know,
in the Andes or were in Peru rather they,
um,
they chew cocoa leaves,
you know,
because they're like way up high in the mountains and um,
they,
they figured out,
well,
what's the best nutrient to help us up here?
Well,
it turns out it's fucking cocaine.
No,
that makes sense.
And the coca leaves.
Yeah.
But people have been taking these extracts like velvet bean,
especially one of the ingredients in Alpha brand.
They've been taking it for thousands of years and it's,
if you think it's too expensive,
I totally understand.
We use the best ingredients available and it's not cheap.
So what I would suggest you do is go to the website.
If you're interested in nootropics,
first of all,
just read up on them.
The Internet is amazing,
right?
Just enter in the word neutral,
big n o tropic.
And you know,
you find out so much information about all the different compounds in different,
different ones that people offer,
not just Alpha brain,
there's a bunch of them on the market and there's a bunch of different
individual ingredients that you can get if you want to try this specific formula
that's an Alpha brain we list on [inaudible] dot com.
Oh,
and it the exact ingredients.
So please just buy it in bulk.
If it's a budget issue,
buy it in bulk and try it and mix it up.
Find out what's good for you,
find out about other things,
run out about some of the other nutrients that are available,
that enhanced cognitive function.
Just fuck around with it if you like to,
if you don't like to,
well not offended,
but it is a sponsor of the podcast.
And if you go to Joe Rogan.net and click on the link for Alpha brain entering
the codename Rogan,
you will get 10 percent off.
A hotly debated issue.
Sam,
triple a lot of people have been giving you are the fifty cents of podcast.
You're pushing product.
I am.
I am pushing a product,
but it's only products that I believe in.
I think the fleshlight is awesome to fuck period.
Hope that pure like vitamin water where you sell it and you got a piece and it's
worth.
I wish I had a piece of the flashlight but they were already huge before I came
along.
But I have a piece of Alpha brain boom,
boom.
But I listen.
If I didn't,
I wouldn't say.
I mean if I,
if I didn't have a piece in it,
I wouldn't say anything different than what I'm saying now.
This is something I believe in.
I might say it less because I'm not trying to sell it,
but I would say the truth and if I didn't believe in it I wouldn't be selling
it.
Period.
You know?
So think what you want.
Try what you like.
Don't be mean on the Internet though.
The troll.
Oh,
and by the way,
100 percent money back guarantee.
One hundred percent.
If at any,
in any,
anytime after you take it,
you're not satisfied.
I don't know how many days is for brain.
What is it?
Like 30 days or something like that,
15 days,
whatever it is,
it gives you a couple of weeks to take it and you will feel some sort of an
effect fairly quick.
How many days you got a ticket to feel an effect right away?
It took me about two weeks,
honestly.
I an effect to feel like I prefer a while.
It was like trying to figure it out,
buddy.
So out of Wack Dude with Sarah.
Wasn't that great?
Wasn't that immediate pussy.
It's like taking the condemned house and throwing down on it and being like,
why don't I look better?
It's like,
it's like I want you to take the test and let me know if you're the same as me
because I took two weeks to figure it out.
I look at our guts.
We have the same problems here,
so like,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't smoke cigarettes,
but we've got the same problem.
You should take a little time.
You might start to show.
You would start this motherfucker,
Sam Tripoli's the house live and crowd.
I was on Ted talk.
What we did was we just push product.
Joe Rogan podcast
can easily
one of the greatest moments in my young life.
How'd that feel?
Fucking awesome.
I didn't know
it was going to say that when Nick Diaz that that was so cool.
Laurie's dude.
I was in my glory's.
I was like,
oh,
this is fucking most awesome shit.
Ever.
That could be better than if he said,
hey,
I am so excited about fucking your TV show coming back like this is even better
at it now.
That's nothing and the podcast is way better.
Yeah,
right.
What are you doing over there,
Brian?
You're going to sniff things.
Smoking Weirdo fucking smelled it for some reason.
I don't know what Mike Pocket Brian's going to be like when he's like 60.
What do you think is going to have the same child?
Their sense of humor just like this,
but I did not realize I did that.
I know.
I have no idea why.
Just did that.
Because you tell so many people to sniff yours at home.
No,
no,
I think it's just with new things.
I like smelling new things,
but I thought I do that.
I smelled things like getting a new laptop or a video game system.
We'd take off that Styrofoam.
We go,
well,
I ate lobster last night and they give you the little bib thing and you gotta
put it on,
you know,
it seems ridiculous,
but my little daughter wanted me to put it on and I decided to smell it.
The Bib smelled gross.
Well,
it's plastic,
but like a weird plastic smell.
Not like the Macdonald Bibs or whatever.
Like throw away ones.
Yeah.
Really?
I am thinking of that age.
I would ever go near lobster.
Yeah,
because it's a kid.
It looks like a monster.
You don't want to go.
They need a octopus real fucking.
There's a.
there's the eat octopus doesn't to like.
No.
Oh my daughters.
I was like,
what optimism is that video?
is that even fucking possible?
Lobsters.
There's a fucking pee.
There's a group of people,
believe it or not.
I called the lobster liberation group and these motherfuckers,
they go out and they break into markets and restaurants and they take the
lobsters out and they release them in the wild.
Could you fucking imagine how dumb you have to be to risk your freedom because
you will go to jail for this or for a bunch of solace fucking bugs or how like
how like Kushy Kushy your life must be that.
That's the problem that you want to solve in the world of all the problems like
you must have your credit cards must be paid off.
Your credit must be great.
You must be on some kind of salary from your parents that you want to go save
little creature from like water.
It's weird.
Yeah,
and little creatures that don't give a fuck about you,
that not only do they not give a fuck about you,
they,
they're too stupid to feel pain,
but what about the thing about the killer whale where they're like people,
that's what they wanted to say,
that they,
they should have the right to people that killer whales are a completely
different animal.
You know,
you're now you're talking about something where I'm probably agree with them.
I think what's going on with killer whales,
killer whales are a super intelligent life form that we can't understand and
because we can't understand them like,
well that's a category and getting a fucking cage then a light going in cages.
They don't like being in those ponds.
They want to be in the goddamn ocean and they're really attached to their
families and they steal them.
They steal them from their fucking mothers when they're,
man,
this is really the most evil shit ever.
You know,
Dolphin Training and Orca training,
it might look cool because they're jumping up to get their fish,
but guess what?
They have to jump up to get their fish.
You don't know how depressed they are.
You don't know how fucked it must be to live that kind of a life.
It's like us getting abducted by aliens and they put us in a really small
apartment complex with a pool and we all kind of hang out at the pool,
you know?
And then that's exactly what it's like for these dolphins.
So,
you know,
as for social world and they can never have freedom,
they can never be free then in that sense,
I think often never over.
It's fucked up for life.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
That's not cool.
I was thinking the other day about how like I just got a dog,
you know,
it's my first responsibility in a long time and uh,
I just watched his dog and all it does is I'm basically can't.
It's like Kathy Griffin's assistant.
I just get ran by this dog constantly.
And algae does is eat poop and eat herself out.
That's pretty much all my dog does.
Jesus stuff out all day,
all day.
It was done a little under a year,
little over a year.
And I'm like,
if aliens come and make us pet,
is this what I'm going to be able to do it because that's not so bad.
Like I could just eat and then suck myself off.
That's ridiculous.
First of all,
you can suck your own Dick.
I can try.
Second of all.
Really?
You don't.
You don't want to have the freedom to go as you choose.
That's ridiculous.
You don't know,
man,
number one thing that would drive you the most craziest to know that your
existence is defined by four walls forever.
That's a for a person.
That's maddening.
The person wants to experience new things,
is a natural thing to check out new movies,
go down to a new restaurant,
you know,
go,
go drive through a new neighborhood.
It's part of what we are.
We like to explore things.
We're curious.
You tell a person and this is all you're going to see this,
the only input you're going to get forever.
They'll go fucking crazy.
It was what we're doing in those dolphins.
That's what we're doing in those orchids.
We just assume that because they can't alter their environment,
that they can't be as intelligent as us,
but they could be a matter of fact,
the cerebral cortex of an ORC is like 40 percent larger than that of a human
being,
so we don't know.
We don't know if that's because it has to manipulate this really super large
body because we do know that neanderthals were dumber than people,
but they had bigger brains.
You know,
so it might have been just too,
because neanderthals had basically like superhero bodies.
They were like an anatomic,
like five,
three,
200 fucking pounds of solid muscle with these.
It's crazy bone structure like a chimp,
but you don't know.
Maybe,
maybe that,
you know,
I mean they could be as smart because they were starting from less.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like we're farther along in the past so we're dealing with more complex shit.
But you had to start at the simple thought and then build on that.
Over time you may have just had the same kind of ability to think,
but you have to start at nothing and build that something.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
We don't quite know whether or not neanderthals were making tools before they
learned them from Homo sapiens either.
They don't know.
There's a lot.
I think there's a lot of debate on that.
I think they think that the homosapiens just fucking basically wiped them out.
We were just too clever,
but that might be wrong.
Who knows?
I mean maybe they were about it.
What if
one of their cell phones,
they send a grated from that long?
That's a good point.
What if,
what if their heads were that big because they were looking on their screens so
much and the Internet made their head's bigger and then they all got wiped out
and died.
And you really think that there could have possibly been an internet at some
point in the past?
Yes,
I think so.
Definitely 100 percent.
Really?
I think so.
How many thousands of years ago do you think it would have to have six?
No,
I'm just kidding.
I mean,
but,
but based on what this is,
30,000 years ago.
Yeah.
So you got to go way back because six,
we know we go to six and we know like,
they know that a Sumerian text they know,
uh,
they wrote the tuner form.
It's just weird.
It looks like little,
um,
like nails,
you know,
like old nails ever see how an old nails,
not like a straight line with a flat top on it,
but it's almost like the whole piece is like,
you know,
angled and that's what they're like writing,
look like,
look like old nails,
like sideways and upside down.
It really weird fucking crazy language when you think about it because it was
all basically most of the same characters just reused in some weird order that
they understood and they had come to agree on.
And so we had to sort of decipher that because it's a dead language.
We don't even know what it sounds like,
you know,
like no one talks it so they,
they know of the Sumerians wrote,
although it's,
a lot of it is under debate because of there's a guy named Zechariah switching.
You've probably heard about him.
I wouldn't trust anyone named Zechariah who was a bad motherfucker,
but he was never.
He was a believer and he believed that the Sumerian texts was all about the
Annunaki,
which is a an alien race from another planet that came down here that isn't an
elliptical orbit,
this planet,
every 3000,
600 years and that they came down here to get humans and they created us from
lower hominids by adding their DNA.
This is all like supposedly in the scenario
I don't have.
You know what man,
when they talk about angels,
you never know man.
There could be some crazy shit coming down.
You know what?
I think
a lot of it probably is what Brian is saying.
A lot of it probably is 30,000 years ago,
not six,
but 30,000 years ago,
there was like a super fucking advanced civilization.
They'd reached the heights that we've reached and what happened?
Who knows
if someone came in his answer,
I think there are way past us and then they invented something that's still with
us that we just don't know even know about yet.
You know,
like they like,
like they,
they invaded like air that could a heel and send information or something like
that.
And we haven't turned into it once we figured out a machine.
Yeah,
I believe in that.
Yeah.
And it's like the Internet.
It's like the version of the Internet now look,
well,
you could never have explained the Internet to somebody 50 years ago.
That's nothing you ever looked at the old videos when they try to explain
computers like in the eighties,
you know what,
what was the thing that they used to use back in the wild west days?
Remember de de de de de de Morse code.
And that,
what they used back in the old wild west days?
No,
it was called.
What was it called?
Um,
it was,
it wasn't called Mars.
You could troll someone so easy on Morris Code.
They'd have no idea it was you,
you know,
it sounds like facebook.
Or let me see your picture.
Take a picture right now of you and put it on your
is what I want you to do.
Want you to wear red,
white and blue socks on.
Old people talk more
imagined back then telling people that you're going to be able to watch people
fuck on your phone.
So look at that,
see my phone,
I can watch people fuck on this.
It will be mind blowing.
You watched me go fuck on it.
It's streams and perfect time.
So yeah,
I mean like just to quantum leap,
I can't,
I can't imagine what's going to be in 10 years.
In 20 years the real,
you know,
there's people that have a real scientific be scientifically based theory that
the entire world that we live in is like a computer simulation and there's like,
you know,
when they start getting into quantum theory and you know,
I don't understand quantum physics and Richard Feynman said it best.
He said,
if you think you understand quantum physics,
you don't understand quantum physics because even the scientists don't really,
they're,
they're still like a lot.
It just violates all these laws.
Like there's things like a particle and being superposition where it's moving
and still at the same time and they can appear in more than one place at the
same time and disappear and they literally,
the particles disappeared.
We don't know where the fuck they go.
They go away and then they come back and on top of that,
particles seem to be interacting with each other despite no matter how long the
distances between them,
they seem to be able to automatically like instantaneously interact with each
other.
That's crazy.
There.
They can interact quicker than the speed of light apparently.
So it's.
I can't even talk about it because I'm not exactly sure what I'm saying.
It's like,
to me it's like what I'm saying is like,
it's like if you taught me how to say something in French,
but I don't know what it means and if you're like xenophobic,
why Misha and then I just replete the noises,
but I don't know what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying right now what I'm talking about this,
you know it's there,
but you're not quite sure what you're saying.
But the bottom line is it's so strange and so bizarre and so not something that
you can bang on.
So not what we're used to in this world that really literally anything is
possible.
This,
this,
this may very well be a computer simulation.
Well,
going back to that computer simulation thing,
that scene in the matrix is kind of what that's about.
Do you know where like neo neo meets like the creator and he talks about how
like he's the eighth one or the 11th one and he's reacting different than all
the other ones.
That's kind of what that's about and that no matter what happens,
people react the same way to stimulate and you hear that a lot about when they
talk about,
you know,
uh,
the Illuminati or whatever,
when they're trying to do a,
they do certain things and see how people will react over time so that when they
want to cause something to happen,
they know the exact reaction of what people mean when they crashed the economy.
They want to see how people react,
all that stuff.
And that was the scene in the matrix where he's like,
you're reacting different than the last seven guys have because it's no matter
what happens,
people are going to do the same thing.
We act like we're different.
And that's a whole thing from talking like your stone.
You're not even a stone.
This is crazy.
That's what that old saying.
Yeah,
that's what he's saying.
Yeah.
He's just.
We don't understand what I'm saying.
I'm not making sense.
You connected a couple of things together that I'm baffled by.
I don't know
the scene in the matrix.
I think I might be on the wrong scene.
Explained to me there's a scene where he walks in.
This is the first matrix.
No,
this is like the second,
third possible.
Why cut off after the first?
No,
you have to go back and watch those without the emotions.
It's so much better.
Without the expectations.
The emotions of this is going to be great.
This is going to be the greatest movie ever.
You put too much,
uh,
too much into it and then you're like,
it doesn't live up to your expectations,
but without those expectations,
it's actually a great movie in the maximum here.
Here's what it is,
buddy.
There was one really good movie and then the next one sucked.
I like the first and second one.
I thought the third one was okay.
Just that one scene was the only problem I have.
Watch them again.
So,
so what are you saying it yet?
What do you say?
So neo walks into this room and he meets the creator of the Matrix and the guy
says that the,
based upon the neos reaction to what he's saying is that he's different than the
rest.
And basically what he's saying is that the human beings,
they keep resetting everything because they keep getting freewill.
They keep fighting back against the matrix.
So they reset everything and everyone reacts the same way.
They reset it and it becomes another computer program and he act,
he acting different than all the past ones.
His emotions are different.
So that's what I'm trying to say.
And then I've read books about how like these guides,
the Illuminati or whatever you want to call them,
who supposedly running the country and the,
you know,
they opened the Federal Reserve and stuff like that from the Federal Reserve.
They created the Federal Reserve.
Sorry about that.
That,
you know,
that is,
that's like one was listening to Magic Johnson today.
Uh,
and he was in,
they were replaying his whole speech about catching the HIV and he used the
wrong words instead of contract says,
I have a penis,
I forget what word you.
I'm like,
Oh,
a speechmaker must have gotten pissed right there.
But back to what I was saying that they,
they do certain things where they just see what the reaction of people will will
be over time.
You should see that movie multiple times and every time you see it you get into
some emotion to it and become a what a mind fuck it would be if you went to a
movie and you know,
like maybe the glitch in the computer program was that when you went to see the
movie the second time,
there was a scene in that wasn't there the first time.
Oh that's cool.
And you're like,
wait a minute,
what,
what the fuck is going on?
No,
the movie ends,
but it's different and you,
you're,
it's a mind fuck because you're like,
God damn,
I don't remember that.
And the people on the other end like,
shit,
I don't think that fucking scene was in the movie.
I don't think we showed them that.
I think we showed him the first version of it.
Fuck.
So this poor guy has got to like wander through,
try to figure out if this going insane.
Imagine if that's what it was.
Insane people are,
it's their program,
their program,
the one that they're living in has a crazy glitch in it.
It's just some glitch.
So just wandering around.
They're all fucked up and homeless.
They're trying to explain the fucking things.
Did you see that video that everyone's got on reddit and they're going after
this kid in Chicago because he,
uh,
he punched this old homeless man in the head and knocked him out
on video.
Yeah.
And then they were laughing about it.
And you see this,
the whole Internet is going after this kid because it's one of the cruelest,
nastiest,
meanest fucking things I've ever seen someone do to an old man who,
a homeless guy.
And he's broke and he's asking people for a young kid,
17,
18,
maybe it looks like your kid,
you know,
I don't know,
it could be 20,
it looks like a kid.
And uh,
he is,
uh,
they're all standing there and this poor guy is like old and rickety and barely
walk.
And the gates of the train opened the doors to train open and he says something
to the old man like,
you want some change?
Oh.
And hits him full blast.
And the old man goes backwards and balances his fucking head off the cement
easily.
Could be dead easily,
could be dead.
You know,
I,
people die like that.
I had a friend who was working in a bar and one of the bouncers punched him on
that lightly.
Same thing,
fell back on his head dead.
It happens all the time.
You're getting hit by the fucking world thinking about what's happening.
The world,
the concrete concrete behind the world is hitting you in the head.
That's really what it's like.
I mean,
it's,
that's an amazing amount of blunt force.
Your fucking son stop.
And this kid just started laughing and they hopped on the train and drove away
and they're all laughing about,
oh shit.
He was
just laughing and laughing and laughing.
The most heartless crew.
It was so disheartening,
man,
that someone could be like that,
that someone could want to do that to someone for no fucking reason whatsoever.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck of you're 15 or 16,
you want to do that,
man,
fuck you.
But you know,
it goes back to this whole thing that sometimes people don't get the discipline
when they're young and sometimes that's like spanking or stuff like that where
they don't realize the pain that comes,
you know,
it's almost like bill burrs bit about how like chicks mess with people because
no one's ever popped them before.
So they video games and porn,
right?
It's just like they don't get it.
So he said that about women.
I've been with women where women want to start fights and that was a fuck you,
you fucking shut your fucking mouth.
And you're like,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck are you doing?
Why are you with me?
And you're yelling at a dude's stop this right now.
What are we going to do it?
You gotta you gotTa beat that guy's ass.
No,
you're going to get me shot.
That's what you gonna do.
Stupid ones.
Craziness.
One hundred percent.
I saw a video like the one you're describing,
it was on television was some.
I don't know what the show was,
but they're showing it and it was this really old guy.
He's about 75.
He's trying.
He is cars right next to this group of like kids talking and he goes to his car.
He's trying to get in.
This other kid comes up and just starts wailing on this.
This old man,
dude,
boom.
All the other people are just standing there watching.
The guy gets in,
his car drives off and the guy just laying down all of his friends,
just all the guys who are watching just walk off,
a stranger has to come up and help them.
I'm like,
so what's the motivation behind this?
Just no motivation.
Stealing his car.
She's crushed.
It's like it's all people,
man.
It's a free shot.
It's free shot at people that feel like they have no friends and they have no
one who loves them and no one gives a fuck about them and they'll just take a
free shot at some old person,
man.
Fuck it.
It's a,
it's,
it's a dark,
dark,
dark part of human nature,
man.
The need to pick on people that need to fuck with people,
you know.
And that's something that we really have to teach our kids.
Man.
You know,
the bullying in schools has gotten worse and worse.
Man,
it's,
you know,
people are bullying people and then taking the pictures and putting them online.
You know,
I saw this picture of this girl,
she blacked out at a party.
She got drunk,
says dude,
shit on her face.
Oh Shit on her face.
Took pictures of it and then put it online.
It's horrible.
She's just cute little cheerleader,
you know,
it's really hard.
Well,
it's funny.
It is funny,
but it's,
it's horrible.
And that's someone's daughter.
Man was a little baby for the rest of her life.
She recognize that.
Are you.
The girl got shit on the fate.
I mean,
it's like,
exactly,
and I can laugh at it,
but pictures.
She had a piece of shit on her mouth.
It's got shit on her mouth.
It's horrible.
Is there no one there going?
What are you doing?
Yeah.
It's not.
That's not that funny.
You don't do that too.
It was a dude.
It would be way funnier,
but doing it to a cute little girl.
It's like,
come on man.
Why you doing that?
So this was a little girl.
Yeah.
And she's a little girl.
She's drinking.
It's like,
why are you shitting on?
Where's your boyfriend?
Where somebody's boyfriend.
She didn't have a boyfriend.
I guess they were drinking.
You know,
should it gets crazy you.
Especially when you're 17,
18,
whatever the hell she is,
you don't know what the hell you're doing.
But I have this thing with the bullies to man.
It's just like I,
I,
I understand the whole move to stop bullying and it's true.
But I have this thing where you got to understand it.
Some of these bullies also are rarely hurt children and they come from bad
situations.
So it's like,
I'm not saying,
Hey,
you know,
let's not stop bullying,
let's,
I don't want,
I hate when adults put their issues on children and because a lot of these
adults got bullied in high school,
they want to go back and clean it up.
But you got to understand that these kids have social issues and mental issues
too,
that you don't want to.
You don't want to tag them with something,
some kind of police record that's going to screw their whole rest of life up
though the rest of their life up.
So.
But you have to protect her,
the other students,
100 percent of the other students.
And you've got to figure out,
you know,
the real issue is parents that do a terrible job of raising kids are never
penalized for it.
You know,
you never get in trouble.
you can do a terrible job of driving your car and you can get tickets.
You know,
you don't.
Nothing happens when you raise a shit kid.
Your kid could be a God damn serial killer.
My dog got sound bites.
Someone I get sued 100 percent.
I'm going to go to jail,
I got a bad dog,
but if you have a kid and your kid goes out and kill somebody,
you're not even somehow responsible for it.
That tried to do that for a while.
Then there was this big bash backlash against Moses.
There was something where like the this one area and I honestly Chicago,
but I'm not 100 percent sure that they were going to try to do something where
parents were going to be held accountable for their children's actions.
It doesn't surprise me.
You kind of should be in some way,
you know,
I mean,
not entirely named me,
but can.
You never know what happens once the kid leaves the nest.
You know,
and what if the kid has a predilection for addiction?
You know what,
if the kid has got that wacky gene,
they can't drink cough syrup or fucking goes on a bender,
you know,
and that is a real gene man.
I think you and I have both seen it.
We all in the comedy world especially,
we know a lot of wacky people that can't smoke.
A joint camp can have a drink,
can't do it,
can't do it.
I don't care what you say.
Everyone's different man.
You know,
I have my own problems with that stuff and uh,
you know,
it's just,
it's like in my family,
they have different forms of it,
you know what I'm saying?
Everyone's got their own kind of little.
They're little vice and I,
you know,
I have my advice too and I just,
it's just I'm all or nothing type of guy.
Well,
I have a very similar personality,
but it's not with substances.
Luckily I take time off of weed all the time.
I'll take a couple of weeks off.
Doesn't,
it doesn't bother me at all.
I'd never feel the need to drink coffee is the only thing that I've ever been
convinced that I was addicted to because I took off once when I was writing,
I was writing right before I did my last special.
I was for every day for 30 days I was writing a blog because I think there's
something about writing everyday.
It really keeps your mind real sharp,
you know,
it's great for performing.
It seems weird,
but writing all the time,
it's great for performance.
So I was drinking a lot of coffee man and then I tried to not have coffee once I
was done and Iud did I get a headache?
I got a 100 percent and I felt like shit.
I felt like really like sluggish and I was like,
oh great.
I'm addicted to caffeine.
So I've done it a couple of times where I've gotten off of caffeine and every
time I've done it I have this weird like for like a couple of days I have a
rule.
I don't drink caffeine after a certain time unless I have to perform and I'm
really sluggish,
but like after 8:00 I try to cut it off because then I can't sleep at night and
I'm twitching and I'm waking up in the middle of it and like to get a good
night's sleep.
I like I,
I stopped drinking coffee.
I'm addicted to.
I have a bunch of different things that I do to get ready for shows,
but the number one best one for sure is warm your body up.
I do a lot of stretching,
stretching is big because when you stretch,
like you really fucking stretch,
you release tension and it just,
you like,
you feel better,
you feel easier,
like tension builds up in you.
So before a show,
like I warm up and I stretch and I learned this new.
I've learned this new breathing stuff from Steve Maxwell.
He's into this,
he's this,
uh,
I'm a fitness trainer world would down really high level fitness trainer.
It's got degrees and he's also a black belt in Jujitsu and he's a,
you know,
a world famous Kettlebell instructor and really cool guy.
But he's basically a,
a guy who's lived his whole life with a passion for fitness,
you know,
so he's always constantly gathering information and one of the things he's been
concentrating on,
his breathing techniques,
he's been concentrated on a Pranayama and all this yoga breathing.
And so we did a bunch of these crazy,
uh,
breathing exercises like,
God damn.
I thought breathing was just bullshit.
I thought it was like breathe through your mouth.
Breathe.
I thought it was just something where you're not being tough enough.
Suck it up,
Pussy Stop,
stop boiling and about how your breathing.
Let's go.
Let's go do another lap.
You know,
like that's what I always stopped breathing was.
But what it is is a,
a much more rapid way of recovery.
This pranayama
breathing and that you can actually control your breath when you become like a,
like a yoga guy,
like a Yogi,
like one of those high level guys,
they actually can control their breath,
like in control,
their heart rate and it,
like they can calm themselves down when they're in periods of stress.
And so I started doing these,
uh,
these,
breathing exercises and it's a fascinating shit.
So that along with stretching,
that's the best shot when I get older,
man,
and I'm not working out,
my breathing goes to shit like when I'm trying to run and stuff like that.
It's like when you get older man,
and you don't work out,
you're rigor mortis starts setting in and that's what you're fighting.
Even though you're still alive,
you're fighting rigor mortis,
setting in and breathing is a big part of that man.
Well,
this maxwell guy is 59 years old.
He's in incredible shape,
dude.
I mean he does shit that I can't do it.
He shows me some things and I can't fucking do them and he's 59 years old.
She's super healthy and just every day,
super shredded and make sure you train every day,
trains everyday and when you do that,
man,
he force your body to work everyday.
Your body just keeps flowing that blood through their keeps building it up keeps
and then you have this bag,
better reserve of energy.
It feel better.
When I see dudes slowly let it slip away and the gut grows and yeah man,
I see.
I just wanted it.
That's why I brought you on this podcast is a fat intervention.
As soon as we leave here,
we're going to go straight to the gym.
We're going to do rounds in the bag.
Don't know about that,
but yeah,
that's going.
Even going back to your,
your writing thing,
it's,
it's.
I tell young comedians like always be writing.
It's a muscle,
you know,
so and also makes you.
It reinforces the fact that you're a professional,
that you have worked to do,
you know,
there's a lot of comics who like to feel like they're just fuck off's and you
know,
they just like to just go on stage and try to remember what their jokes are and
don't write anything down.
You can do that.
You chuckled.
Junkies,
they're very nervous about not getting the laugh.
They're afraid of that.
They're afraid of that silence.
Terrifying.
Sometimes I just don't mind the silence and then sometimes what I like to do
now,
if I run into a really shitty crowd,
I like to go on my ipod and I get pocket Sitcom and I add my own laughter to the
crowd because sometimes I don't like the crowd and I'd rather have my own life's
going so I'll do this and to the crowd or something like that.
I'll do.
I'll just go and just enjoy my own laughter.
You did,
you know,
this is an Internet meme and then have you ever seen those where it says you're
doing it wrong?
Yeah.
So that's what I do now.
Well that's ridiculous,
Sam.
Well,
I sometimes the crowds just staring at me and I just don't feel that I did.
The way the deal is you to get your own crowds.
That's when the world changes.
It's real hard to like when you show up at the store on a Tuesday night.
That's why everybody likes doing that.
Like people with the real reason why people like to stop in and places is
because until you become like really super famous where every crowd is your
crowd,
Chris rock or something like that.
You know,
when you just stop in,
then you get sort of a slice of people that,
you know,
they're,
they're not,
they're not as inclined to laugh at you.
They're not like super
psyched to have seen you.
Like all my God,
we're going to go see Damon Wayans.
We're so pumped up.
Big Difference between that and then sitting in the audience.
Oh,
Damon Wayans is here.
You know,
so he's going to get a much more honest response from,
you know,
I've seen that before to see comics who get out of there like,
uh,
I'm not gonna say names,
but you see him there in the crowd.
They're crushing.
Take them out of their crowd.
It's just like,
well I'm back in the gym.
I got to work out,
you know,
so it's like,
yeah man.
I mean once you have a big crowd,
once you have your crowd,
it's easier to work on new finds a crowd sometimes.
I don't know man,
I just enjoy just going up there.
I only do that when I'm doing like.
What'd you say?
Not everybody finds a buddy will sometimes you have a crowd there.
I think they're all at yourself short.
Well they are definitely all fucked up.
I hate to say these are the same.
Those are St Louis people too,
man.
I ain't mostly crazy.
My cloud fucked up but like to drink.
Cool as fuck.
So the mind man,
my crowd is always fucked up.
I have more pot smokers.
I need to do that probably,
you know,
big pot smoker guy,
but you do.
Sometimes you go in these waves.
Depends on where I'm at right now.
That's doing Sam Tripoli's on and I'm sober wave and you know,
it works better,
but my problem is when everything works better.
A dude listen.
I like the party dude.
I like to get out there.
I like to go,
go nuts.
Yeah.
I'm a Nazi Guy Dude,
because I just,
I want it all.
I want to do everything.
I just,
that's how I am man.
And you know,
you're funny.
It's while you're crazy impulsive.
Yeah,
I'm not.
I want everything to be the greatest story of our life.
Every time I go out at night drink I'm like,
I want this to be legendary moment.
And people are like,
oh my God.
Last night we were with AAA.
Shit got crazy.
And you know what?
That catches up with you after awhile and I,
I know just sipping a beer or just like,
that means that does nothing for me.
Are you working this Friday?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm in La Jolla.
Why?
Because I'm doing the comedy Magic Club in Hermosa Beach.
You're killing me dude.
I love the.
I love that place and fun.
He's so nice.
Man.
Looks to be about twice a year and a and I'm not right for his crap.
I mean like I am,
but even my nice stuff has a little edge to it,
you know what I'm saying?
But he's so nice to put me up,
you know?
And uh,
I love playing that crap.
I love editing myself as I go because the nicest guy ever.
It's just a nice fun club and it's a great club.
But he allows me,
you know,
well,
because you bring a certain crowd that packs bringing them in,
but he won't let joey.
Oh really?
I've had joey a couple of times.
It's too extreme.
Crazy.
We started talking about stuff and things up.
You're muffling yet he lifts are,
which makes no sense.
Well,
Ari,
apparently his sister.
A little different dirt.
Well first of all,
he's Jewish so he gets a little pastor.
That's right,
Annie.
And he looks,
he doesn't,
he's not threatening.
You're going,
oh my God,
he's going to bang my daughter tonight at your
daughter tonight.
He doesn't know.
You look like he's from here.
He goes back to the library and he starts working on a dewey decimal system.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's like I don't look at it that way.
I look at dirty guys as having just as much of a density for anger and violence
as a as scary looking people because Nerdy,
a lot of times when you kitchen nerdy person,
you're catching them when they're fucking about to break.
You know their whole life.
Someone's been fucking with them their whole life.
Girls have been shitting on them and fucking they're ex boyfriends behind their
backs.
People have been stealing their lunch by stuffing them into lockers,
so when the shit goes wrong with the nerdy guy could get crazy quick.
Nothing falling down,
Bro.
Exactly,
exactly.
Falling down.
I know a lot of nerdy dudes that are suicidal too and know.
I know.
I know some nerdy dudes that you know,
especially when they get into their thirties,
you know,
and their body starts to slow down when they're,
they're still unhappy with life.
It gets tricky man.
And when you're running a suicidal person,
you know,
if they're willing to kill themselves,
the fuck are they willing to do to you 100 percent man.
Watch your p's and q's around crazy sun,
super hot chicks who are suicidal.
I mean because it's their reality.
You're looking at them going,
you're hot,
you have.
Everybody was bending over backwards just to sniff your,
your magic and at the but in their head they're like,
they're miserable.
It's not enough.
You need a lot of things to be happy in this life,
man.
You need,
you need fulfillment.
You need love,
you need friendship.
You need honesty.
You need honesty about yourself.
You need to be able to assess your strengths and your weaknesses and find your
goals and achieve them.
And you need a lot of fucking things to be happy.
You need,
you need,
you know,
when I say find your goals and achieve them,
I mean like,
you know,
not necessarily like your ultimate goal to be happy,
but you have to do.
People require improvement in their life to be happy and it might be improvement
of just you.
I'm going to paint,
I'm going to paint a landscape scene,
get it done,
and you look at it,
I fucking did it.
You know,
when I,
whenever I do anything,
whether it's a podcast or I write something,
that feeling that you get when you're done like I did it.
You need that to be happy.
You got to just be a lazy fucking sit around doing nothing while know a hundred
percent and I'm to just going to drink and fucking suit outside.
You were going to get bored,
man.
You're gonna want to do something?
The idea of the ultimate idea of ultimate vacation is a stupid idea.
Uh,
you know,
even when I go on vacation,
I'm good for like a day and then I want to do something.
I want to do some shit.
So then it's vacation.
What's go do fun shit.
While we're on vacation,
but the idea of just sitting and just drinking in front of a fucking ocean for
three days like Jesus Christ,
how long can you do that?
What kind of attention span do you have?
But do you have a day of rest?
One day?
Yeah.
That's my son.
Sit down one day,
Sunday.
I just don't.
I try not to do shit,
but I sometimes I don't feel like I deserve it,
but I don't feel like I deserve it.
I won't give them feel guilty sometimes,
but I feel like you have to have that moment of just relax.
You Do,
you do.
But I think you have to earn it in my mind.
For me to be happy,
I have to earn it.
I have to make sure that I've not like slacking off about a bunch of shit that
piles up in your subconscious because that's the shit that fucks with you when
you're on brownies and that's the shit that fucks with you.
And when you're in the isolation tank,
when I'm in the isolation tank,
everything that fucks with me as things that I'm not doing,
it's 100 percent things that I'm not doing or some mean stuff I said to someone
when I was 10 or something.
Like sometimes that'll come back and you'll get some weird memory of that.
But for me like you know,
where I am in my life and what I've done and all that stuff,
I have one thing someone said to me is I asked them how they were doing.
They go a lot better than I think I am know.
Because sometimes people like Neal Brennan,
you're doing,
you're actually probably doing better than you give yourself credit for.
But you know,
sometimes people focus on what hasn't happened yet or you know,
then what has gone well in their life.
And a lot of people sometimes compare their insides to other people's outsides.
And that's where you start getting really weirded out.
Like when you start looking at this guy and he's got what you've always wanted
or you think you've always wanted and you're like,
oh I don't get anything.
And you don't realize how much you've done with your life.
I'm really just in the moment of there's tons of stuff I would love to do and
I'm working on doing.
But like at the end of the day,
like from what I've wanted to,
I've done a lot of it.
There's a lot more to do,
but I've done a lot of it.
The most important thing to me when you have that feeling,
you compare yourself to other people.
This is not a bad thing to do,
but what you gotta do is only be inspired and have that as an ethic.
Don't ever be jealous.
Don't ever be Uber self critical or down yourself instead of.
Yeah.
Instead of going,
I'm fucking lazy piece of Shit,
you know,
look at this guy's doing his fucking second comedy central special and I don't
even have a fucking hour and a half that I really like,
you know,
this is my socks and I can't keep a relationship.
Instead of saying that instead of saying that,
watch some guy that you really love or respect or in instead of,
you know,
instead of being put down by it,
be elevated because $100 got it.
You can choose to do that,
man.
People could choose to do that.
Yeah,
you might.
You might be right.
You might be a lazy piece of Shit.
You might be right,
but don't think about it.
Don't concentrate on that because if you concentrate on the fact that you're a
lazy piece of Shit,
you will continue to manifest that reality.
It sounds like hippie bullshit.
Fucking true.
Energy and intent.
I have some thoughts,
man about about reality and I have some thoughts about the use of the mind and
the imagination of how it sculps reality.
I don't think it's as simple as they want to break it down and like the secret
and the law of attraction and I put a picture of this house on the wall.
Yeah.
That's where years later I was moving into that house.
I don't think it's that,
but I think it's kind of that.
I think there's something to the idea that your thoughts and imagination have an
effect,
a reality.
This isn't my reason why I say this because I think the imagination is something
that we're not taking it as seriously as we should be,
and what I mean by that is that I don't think.
If you looked at like what?
What part does this play in life?
What part does food play in life?
What part does the.
The imagination has a huge impact on our reality because we take things out of
the imagination and we build them like this fucking laptop.
It's came from originally from someone's idea and it blossomed and evolved into
what you see in front of you,
but it came out of the imagination.
It came out of the air.
Someone figured out how to put something together because they had an idea.
They had a spark.
They saw the vision,
they saw it feel fully formed in their mind or they saw steps along the way
fully formed and they figured out how to do that.
I think your mind doesn't just control things in a sense that you bring things
out of the ether,
you bring things out of your imagination and bring them and manifest them in the
real world,
but I think your mind actually has an effect on how things go in the real world.
As I said before,
don't.
I don't understand quantum physics,
I don't get it,
but I do know that they've done tests where they show that particles react
differently if you're observing them than if you're not observing them and I
think there's probably something,
some unmeasurable thing that's too fucking freaky and far out and really
difficult to prove,
but I don't think it's outside the realm of possibility that there's your mind
might have some sort of an impact on reality.
You know,
babies are still going to get killed by drive bys and people are still going to
get caught in avalanches just randomly.
To me,
it's not.
Not to say that shit can't happen.
Shouldn't most certainly can happen and most certainly there are natural
occurrences that are going to be absolutely beyond anyone's control.
You know,
there's levels of experiences like you know,
you get to a meteor impact,
that's a wrap.
Maybe 65 million years ago,
a big one slammed in and there's nothing bigger than a fucking hamster lived.
That's it.
Boom.
And that could happen again and no,
no matter how much imagination you have and how much you,
you,
you dream of a perfect world.
I don't know if you can prevent that.
I think that there might be quantum things,
there might be macro things that might be a whole bunch of things working
together,
but I don't discount the idea that you can use your own mind and you're in your
own imagination to manipulate reality to a certain degree.
Now,
100 percent,
I've always felt felt the energy you give out sometimes most of the time here,
Angie,
you get back.
How about dudes who just force shit with their mind?
You know,
this is going to sound crazy,
but when Dane Cook became really famous,
that was one of the first things that I thought of and I was like,
wow,
this guy wanted it so much that he figured out a way to make it like Dane Cook,
we all have talked about it in the comedy world.
That was a real shocker for a lot of us were like,
wow,
how did he do that?
That's amazing.
How do you get that big,
that big,
that big.
Yeah,
but the whole thing,
you can always point.
You could always tell someone's going to work and I always felt,
you know,
he's,
he's a different person right now.
I feel that that when I him,
which was many years ago,
was way different now because it's successful and he sort of relaxed and he's
realized that things in his life have happened that made him reassess where he
wants to be and what he has brought us.
We want them all.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But he was a win at all cost guy.
Yes,
exactly.
And with that comes a certain price and you know,
I've always said that and not that he's a bad person,
but I've always said sometimes bad things happen to good people,
but I always felt bad things always happen to bad people and it may not be
instantaneous and it may not have the board bad.
Maybe isn't the right way to describe somebody.
But I feel like if you're always putting out energy and you're,
you're,
you're fucking over your fellow man to,
to win almost.
It's going to come back.
And it might not be instantaneous.
Meaning if I fuck you right now that you know I'm going to walk out and get hit
by a car,
you never know.
Well,
this is what I think.
I think that the only time that doesn't work as associate paths,
because sociopaths don't seem to have any feelings about things like that.
They don't worry about hurting people's feelings.
They don't,
they don't feel connected.
But the real problem with regular people like you and I,
is that you feel connected with someone when you hurt their feelings.
Like I've had people that are hecklers there that are just idiots and they're
ruining a show.
There's a thousand people in there and one person wants to,
wants to fucking throw in their own stupid brain and and slosh up the whole
show.
So I'll destroy this person,
I'll torture them.
I break down their life,
but I feel bad.
I don't feel good about it.
I don't want to do that.
I want everybody to have a good time.
I don't want to hurt this guy's feelings.
And as the guys leaving,
fuck you,
you're fucking zero.
And I'm like,
come on man,
I'm at least on one or a two.
This is ridiculous.
And everyone's laughing and I'm like,
what the fuck are you 100 percent.
He crazy asshole.
100,000 people here and you're trying to ruin their night and people are
screaming and cheering.
This guy's leaving.
And as the guys leaving,
I feel bad.
I do like,
does he want his night's ruined?
Yes.
I don't want to hurt him,
but you really just want to
perform and entertain people that paid money to see exactly.
I don't want to hurt anybody's feelings.
I think people that that hurt people's feelings,
even if you justify it,
you know you did something and I think the thing that fucks with your head and
it devalues you in your own eyes.
You're not a hero in your own eyes.
You're not,
you're not someone who you respect,
you know you're doing what you gotta do to get by,
but ultimately you're not respecting yourself.
And I think we all have a certain amount of appreciation and respect for hero
figures.
You know,
like we all look at like the guy who never lies and it always does the right
thing and fucking helps everybody out.
And that's the John Wayne character.
You know,
that's,
that's the,
the ultimate hero.
And when you look at your own life and you don't stack up,
you're a thief.
You stole money from your wife's purse and you know you don't want to smoke
cigarettes,
but you fucking have to.
You can't deal with the stress.
You smoke,
you devalue yourself.
You slowly start devaluing yourself.
You will.
You look at yourself,
you realize that if you were judging yourself,
you would judge yourself unfavorably.
If you're stealing,
if you're hurting people,
so no matter who,
you can't pretend you're the the,
the,
the hero of your story.
You can't.
You have to be the hero of your own story and you can do that.
You can be the hero of your own story that woke up today.
You can be the hero of your own story that at 40 years of age stopped,
got out of bed and said,
I'm not doing this anymore.
I'm doing this different Andrea.
I am going to figure this out and I want to do it only by my instincts and only
by my morals and my ideals and my mind and I'm going to be dead honest with
myself because I'm realizing this is not going to last forever and I'm going to
be the nicest fucking human being to everyone.
I meet possibly,
and I'm going to get myself in shape,
but I'm going to eat healthy and I'm going to do this because this is.
This is me.
Now.
I decided that this is me and people have to realize that you are not your past.
You are not all the times you fucked up,
you are not all the times.
You couldn't get it up,
you're not all the times you were drunk and you know,
and you threw up in someone's car,
you that's not you,
but you,
you are the person who's learned from a great deal of experiences that if you
learn correctly and if you process them correctly,
you'll have a happier life.
You know,
in recovery.
That's a big part of it.
When they,
you know,
you're supposed to list all the stuff you've done and apologized to them and
you.
What it is is you just get it out and you're like,
I did this.
I'm sorry.
Now it's gone.
You have done.
And usually the person you admit to,
they'll be like,
I did all that and a little more.
Look where I am,
it doesn't define you.
And that's the truth.
And sometimes people hold onto that.
So you know,
psychological stuff like athletes and entertainers.
Sometimes they'll do something and something bad will happen and it almost like
wounds them.
It's like high school,
so in shit,
Anya,
it sticks with us instead of understanding that that was a moment in time and
that person was probably hurt themselves.
It doesn't define you as a person.
Yeah.
You,
we all do things that were not happy that we did.
But that doesn't mean that's you now,
you know,
I mean,
do you know going to.
You got to learn that and the,
the thing about apologizing to someone once you get it out there,
once you've relieved this tension,
then it's no longer this burden that you're carrying around because otherwise
you have like burdens.
Like I seriously,
I was all think about some shit that happened from fucking 20 or 30 years ago
and I'll be like,
oh,
I should have been nicer to her.
Or Oh,
I shouldn't have talked to him that way and it will,
it will fuck with me.
Like 20 or 30 years later,
there's this girl named Aaron mcnally.
I went to school there and I went to my last reunion just hoping that she would
show up because during elementary school we treated her so badly and I hated it
and it wasn't part of it,
but I,
I saw it happening,
but I wasn't strong enough to cause I was a kid.
I've always wanted to like,
just be like,
I'm sorry that that had happened,
man.
Yeah.
Well when I was a kid,
um,
especially as I got older and it was more and more angry,
I became,
uh,
the first person to pull the trigger.
I was like the first person to insult someone because I figured,
well,
you're going to insult me so I'll get you first.
You know,
and you know,
you,
you develop this sort of a protective personality like that.
Especially if like you're a little guy and people want to fuck with you.
And that was me.
And
when you do that,
you know,
you all of a sudden that'll be a way you behave now.
And then you'll say things like,
I don't even say that that's,
that's such a Douchey fucking thing to say,
but it's just a purely.
It's based purely on insecurity.
We used to,
I used to call it the triple a low blow where we would be like having,
what are you doing over there,
buddy?
You want to participate in the conversation?
And there's no way I could do that
anticipating this conversation because it was so long winded.
I don't even know what you guys were talking about near the end.
I know we're talking about to break it down for her and it's like a two year old
boy.
No,
I mean I got the,
the main point near the beginning and then it was kind of like I just stopped
listening.
You know,
I,
I have a real problem like in school with anything when it,
when something gets really deep into a conversation and less,
it's about something that I'm totally interested in,
like to solve some kind of mystery.
Uh,
it's,
I,
I just lose interest in it.
How about we talk about are you going to stink,
dude,
you fucking shoes.
But really think something's wrong with my feet right now.
It's wrong.
Or is it your shoes?
I think these shoes are fucked up.
This is the grossest thing ever.
When someone takes their shoes off track right next to you.
But did you smell it?
I smell it.
Just smelled it right when he said it.
I'm going to light some incense.
You Stinky motherfucker.
I have really old gym shoes on because I was moving on.
Let's talk about whether Brian's going to be okay with a tranny being on the
podcast tomorrow.
So who is this girl guy?
It's a listen,
here's my whole thing,
man.
I'm already,
you know this person.
By the way,
did you meet this person?
Meet this person at a bar or a friend.
Now what a bitch.
I just feel like in the naughty show is I want to explore all stuff and I'm fine
with anybody.
Do whatever they want with the consenting adults.
And so,
you know,
you can't do naughty show and it just can't be like,
let's Bang Pornstar.
I want to explore everything and all the different aspects of not just sexuality
but just people.
And their behavior and everything like that and I just wanted to and I thought
it might be interesting to have her on and see what that's like.
How do you get.
I'm always interested.
I mean,
it's a funny subject.
I'm glad you brought this up because I wanted to talk about this very subject
because so many on the message board printed.
Uh,
he goes,
uh,
I organized my porn folder.
That was the thread and it look at it and it's like 80 percent she mails and
trannies and everybody was like a trolling,
like what,
what are you doing with your trail?
You joking around like what are you doing?
And um,
it was basically what he was doing was getting the conversation started and then
as you go to the conversation starter,
it's like,
no,
I'm in a regular girls.
But uh,
I,
you know,
I do watch a lot of tranny porn.
I've had some training x escorts and like super honest about it.
And everybody's like,
whoa dude,
you got balls.
But not really.
I mean,
yes,
he definitely has balls,
but it's a cool environment that you're doing it in.
Like that's the best way to use the Internet if you've got some crazy fucking
freak thing and you can talk about it and your name is,
you know,
mock ficky 50,
right?
No one's going to know who you want.
Let's.
You can make
up whatever the fuck you want your name to be and then you know,
it's just a character on a message board.
Who knows if he's even telling the truth.
I mean,
it might just be an ultimate troll.
People love to do things like that and then giggle and pretending I'm pretending
I'm Brazilian.
People love doing things like that.
I just found it,
you know,
it's like sort of two biggest porn types out.
The genres are interracial and tranny porn because I missed a bit.
One of the biggest,
the two biggest wow.
You would know because folks,
this is not coming out of a manager.
That's the person that's coming to the studio.
That's a tranny.
Whoa.
That looks like a dude.
Yeah.
Some of them,
when they go to fuck when they go too far with the makeup here,
trannies,
let me give you a little piece of advice.
You're better off looking sort of like a man with less makeup than look like a
tranny with a lot of makeup because when you have a lot of makeup on,
it always looks like you're trying to.
What am I trying to trick me?
They try to go look like lumberjacks.
What guys are really at all around with the lesbian.
Butch was the ones that don't want to work.
They look like hot chicks,
right?
Lipstick,
lesbians,
and they're my fans.
Well those are the ones that don't want to work.
I did.
They are.
They want a woman to come along and take care of him the way a man would.
They want a woman to be like their bodyguard and they're usually passing through
just Chaz Bono them,
you know,
100 grand that look like Larry the cable guy.
That's so fucked up.
Is that what it costs?
100 grand.
You know what's weird about Chaz Bono?
Look,
first of all,
I don't.
I would never criticize someone who's doing that because I don't know what the
fuck.
It's like.
I don't know what the inside of his body.
I don't know.
I don't think I have no problems with it.
Be Yourself,
but don't tell me.
It's a little weird.
Okay.
Like,
you know,
it's like if your cat starts barking like a dog,
it's a little weird.
I'm not saying it's wrong and I totally support his right to do it,
but it's not normal.
Normal.
I don't think she's saying it's not.
I think.
No,
I think that's what exactly do you call it here?
She,
I call me.
He at now I call my he.
Yeah.
That's why he is now.
Respectfully.
Yeah.
I have to see his dick called me.
Hey,
that's my idea.
Say Hey,
what's up Chaz?
I wouldn't say he or she may.
We'll just call him a chest.
The navajos thought that there was four basics,
a basic sexist,
that it wasn't for preferences.
It wasn't male females,
male,
female,
masculine woman,
Feminine Male,
and then they thought that makes sense.
Just a natural thing.
And then there was always people that wish they were born a girl and it was.
And I believe it,
I,
100 percent believable.
There's just too many people.
I mean,
I know it could be just nutty people,
it could be some weird imbalance.
It's one thing that has proven that experiences will literally shape the mapping
of your fucking mind and the way your mind makes correlations and the way you
know and even shape your jeans.
You know that it's genes are activated because of certain stresses and different
things that happened to you like literally in the womb.
Man.
You know?
That's why so many people that come from really super volatile environments are
really quick to jump and be violent and the reason being is that they're fucking
program to say,
Hey,
we're going to shoot you out in the middle of a fucking war zone.
Okay?
When you come out,
it's craziness right out the get go.
Your mom almost got shot today coming home from work and you experienced all
this inside the womb that your body's like getting ready for war.
It's triggering set as triggering everything in variances and you draw from
those experiences on how to react to it.
Search in certain situations,
but the back to the training stuff is like,
I believe it's like gay training wheels that.
No,
it's not that.
but why it's so popular on the Internet.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
The porn.
Yeah.
Why is it so popular?
Videos?
I think there's a broad spectrum.
That's what I think.
I think,
you know,
I think there's a broad spectrum of,
of uh,
sexual likes and dislikes and some guys literally get off and they're not even
gay.
They get off on looking at other guys' dicks.
They'll get off on looking at a guy's dick being hard to imagine it was there.
Dick.
And they get little literally low watch porn and get off on the dix.
Well,
I think that's why interracial porn.
So they just love watching.
These are just big bazooka was just destroying these little girl.
I don't know.
I don't understand that because I can't relate because it's not like that's a
black dick.
That's not my Dick.
That's all I was looking at it.
That's why like when I see a dude's got a little tiny deck,
I'm like,
come on son.
That ain't my deck,
I can't pretend this is my deck.
So this is like fun porn for me.
This is my little Dick Porno guy.
Plenty.
A little dig porno guys.
Like how?
What's little like?
I don't,
I've never big.
I can't relate.
Six,
seven,
sometimes fat guys to fat guys with little digs and some dudes love that shit
because I go there could be me,
man.
I was amazed that there's not more of that.
Like because that's what porn start out really ugly guys begging super hot
chicks because that was the fantasy.
Well,
have you seen some of the new porn that they're doing with the porno?
Stars will fuck a fan?
Yeah.
The fuck a real fan.
And they'll let the fan come inside of them and everything like damn.
Oh,
that's what my,
uh,
at my naughty show they wanted a director wanted to come and raffle off to,
one of the co selling and the,
I don't know that the establishment was like,
I don't know,
that's legal.
Which establishment cheetahs?
They said,
no,
Jesus Christ.
How is it not illegal?
He just arranging,
there's no money being taken change.
Something weird had happened.
Like arranging pornography if something weird.
That's their whole theory to get some fucking savage.
Yeah,
you could raffle it off and you could say that your buddy one.
Who's a fucking.
I got bay,
a Buchi straight Outta jail dude.
Yeah,
just kill it.
Just kind of doing ultimate kiss night or something.
It would be fucking her on the camera though,
Dude.
I mean it would be like a video that they make there.
That's their whole thing.
Someone bad,
they could be liable.
I'm like,
I don't know how,
but.
So they didn't want to do it.
I thought it was going to be hilarious.
Changed the wording though,
like ultimate kids night.
Like make it something like that.
Like it was implied that everyone knows.
I mean it doesn't.
Howard stern do that though.
He sets it up where they go and fuck God.
Fuck guys.
I ran it by Cheetah and they were cheetahs and they were like,
you said it really well.
You know what it is
men.
No.
You know what it is the risk for reward for them.
It's not worth it.
What are they going to do?
They're going to make a couple hundred people happy if they do it and what's the
risk?
The risk is they get known as a prostitution established.
They get fucked and they lose their license.
That's the risk.
It's like,
why would they do that for your silly little fucking comedy show?
Silly boy.
Nonbusiness sense having motherfucker.
This is my business had been in vegas for 17 fucking years.
Dislocation.
Yeah.
Do it with a French accent.
Cheetahs.
Not French guy.
Then they cannot do this now.
The French are freaks,
man.
Fuck.
They don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
Have you been to a strip bar and a la lately?
No.
They're horrible.
Really horrible.
It's been hard.
It's never been a good one and there's no number that bit that I used to do
about the star strip.
Unless you.
Annika.
No,
it was a true fucking story.
The girls dancing and I asked her.
I go,
Hey,
is this fun for you?
Do you like doing this?
She goes,
I don't talk to guys.
You come here and I go,
well,
why not?
She goes,
well,
you know what?
Most of the guys who come here are assholes,
so I don't talk to guys to come here.
And I go,
well,
it's an open door.
I mean,
like Nice people come into it at all,
you know?
And she goes,
well,
the only come here for one reason.
I mean like,
why'd you come in here?
And I go,
because somebody told me there was a place that I could go where I could see a
strange girl's pussy for A.
Oh,
I remember that.
I remember that bit.
That's a true story that really did happen.
I was like,
what a gross conversation.
I just,
you dancing if,
if you don't want to talk to me,
just say,
you know,
uh,
I would prefer to be silent or something.
But see,
most guys are assholes.
Like,
okay,
I get it.
I get,
this is not fun all the time,
but I'm nice.
I'm being nice to you.
Yeah,
sure.
There's a lot dick's going in there,
but it's like,
that's your job.
I mean,
it's like there's a bit of sales,
but you should totally open up a club in.
It's called Houston's and fly just there.
All the girls there are just from Texas and they get flown in every week.
We're going to be cool.
No,
it wouldn't be.
Why wouldn't be a bunch of fucking problems.
That's what you got.
I mean if you.
If you want to.
What it is is these are people that are broken.
That's what it is.
I mean the reason why this girls angry at work is not because not even
necessarily because so many guys are assholes,
which I'm sure they are just because the reason why she's fucking got her
asshole in front of your face in the first place she's broken.
Something happened is poor girl when she was younger and she's all fucked up and
most likely molested and then here we go.
There's good la club or there's good strip clubs though.
You enjoy going to good strip clubs in la or just completely broken because of
the actress thing.
Exactly,
and less and less as I can only enjoy it with a bunch of people and less and
less and less and less.
I enjoyed then when I was younger and it's just because I do the math,
you know,
he'd do that whole fucking Buddhist thing where you start to think about what is
the cause and effect,
what is the,
what is the initial starting point for this per the current behavior.
Or you have a couple of drinks and you just go stare at Ted's.
Do you hear about the place in North Dakota?
There's a city where they've like some mining city where the girls are stripping
and they're making $3,500 a night course.
They got so much money and there's like five chicks in the whole entire town and
they're taking.
They're taking in applications from all around the world,
like Russia a check chicks.
Oh yeah.
I was talking to some dudes up in Canada.
We were working,
we were in grand prairie and some shit like that.
And we're way the fuck up there.
And they were talking to us about the,
the,
um,
there's a lot of dudes that work up there in the minds and that there's nothing
to do up there.
And they make a shitload of money,
shitloads of money to shit.
Loads of cash.
That was my job when I her up.
They come in from Europe for gigs there.
Yeah.
I have rules with women.
I won't fuck three types of chicks under age,
married or Russian chicks to the Russian dude.
One,
they may not be there by choice.
And two,
you don't know man.
Those chicks are just as crazy,
man.
They come in,
they'll slice and dice and motherfuckers the craziest,
which I ever used to fuck around with was a Ukrainian girl.
Right.
She was wild.
I still beat off to that girl and they always want to get married.
Like after like two months,
I need a ring.
Put a ring on this finger.
Yeah.
Well she was a second generation,
but God damn,
this bitch was a freak.
Like the craziest white girls,
black girls.
But they're there.
They're just like,
they have a.
they're a much hardier stock than your average white girl.
It's like almost like there's almost like a different species and the men too,
you know,
if you look at guys like fate or and.
Oh,
or the fucking hard Russian men.
There's some fucking hard Russian men.
They always had that country's strength.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
like a whole country full of Matt.
He uses faith just like they look like they fight grizzly bears.
It's a tough.
I mean,
look,
there's Russian pussies,
just like,
you know,
American pussies.
They're all kinds of pussies in this world,
but Russians are some fucking tough fucking people,
man.
Yeah,
they are.
They've been through some crazy shit.
Armenians.
Armenians are nuts.
Some people are fucking people,
man.
Out of Armenian fighters,
dude.
Lot of MMA fighters,
lot of Moitai,
Armenian fighters.
A lot of medium boxers,
taxi drivers.
When you think of anything.
When I moved to La,
that was the weirdest thing because where I was from the,
you know,
the means where I'm from are very like,
they look like white people right out here.
They're very Persian army.
Where are you from?
The upstate New York and they look like white people.
They look,
if you looked at all my aunts,
you'd be like,
Oh,
a couple of my aunts were like,
wow,
those are white people.
You would never know they were Armenian.
Where did,
how did uh,
Amenia get it's Armenia Armenian night.
How did they get there?
They're like their ethnicity,
like what do they come from?
Is it a mix of Filipinos are Chinese and Spanish,
like out here they're mostly a Persian,
Armenian,
Persian army,
Persians.
But the country,
uh,
adopted Christianity.
So it became it's own little thing and it never really got along with any of.
It's like neighbor.
So it was the Persians came into Iran and then became Christians.
Know the Persians.
Yeah.
Well it was one whole thing.
I mean,
I came into Armenia and then became a Christian.
The country was the first country that ever adopt Christianity as it's
countries.
Uh,
official religion.
So,
okay.
There's like
the darker,
more Middle Eastern Looking Armenians.
And then there's more like,
like,
like European,
European,
very light skin,
very light skinned.
You would never know.
Did they take you the same way though?
Because I know that there's,
like with Mexicans,
there's a big difference in Mexico.
Coconuts will you get with Mexicans,
you get dudes who look like Oscar de la Hoya or Salma Hayek who looked very
Spanish,
very European,
or then you get dudes who look more like Indians.
Really more like native Americans because that's the real bloodline.
Like the Mayans.
What about the one Mexican boxer who looks red headed Irish?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just bought Lucy did lucy case Mexican too?
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
He was born in Mexico.
He's Mexican.
Not Born in Mexico,
but he's Mexican.
Wow.
I never knew that.
That's what he has a joke about how he's more Mexican than Carl has been seeing
and he really is.
I mean,
Louis is Mexican.
Yeah.
Very fascinating.
Just how.
No,
no,
no.
I don't know.
He's got a lot of Mexican animal,
but um,
there's a,
there's a very distinct look that,
uh,
some Mexicans have,
you know,
it's,
it's more of an American Indian look know sort of.
When I went to mek combination,
I went to Mexico City to see metallica and uh,
we flew in and my friends were already there and we didn't know what to do.
So we're like,
oh no one's here to pick us up.
We were going to go.
We were like,
we need a ride.
So we find a taxi and it gets shady.
Dude detects drivers like follow me man.
We walked through the airport and as we get through the airport we keep walking
and gets more and more third world,
so I'm not lying to you.
Eventually were walking out the airport through this back alley where there's
these chickens all running around and I'm like,
this is not going right man.
And we got into the car.
I made a video of it and he drove around and like that's the worst thing you can
do in Mexico City is getting a taxi because they will kidnap you.
They'll drive you somewhere,
they'll take you in the hold you for a couple of days until they drain your atm
and if you're lucky they'll let you come back.
But I don't know.
This guy liked us,
we started talking about hookers and all that stuff because there's something
about me whenever I land to do stand up or do somewhere,
I always asked,
so what's going on in this town?
And they always tell me where the hookers are.
The immediately,
the first thing they always tell me is like,
oh,
you can get some girls over here.
I don't know what it is.
You seem like a party guy.
I see,
but do I look like I need hookers?
Yes.
Really?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean that's cool.
That's a cool color.
You'd like him like you could tell like I don't want to.
I just want to talk to them and get to know them.
And the hooker whisper.
Yeah.
Mexico is a very tricky place.
Last time I was there I was in Cancun.
It was a few years back and I remember landing and walking through the airport
and just all these people like coming at you to try to give you a ride.
And I was like,
well we are a ride already range where I was like,
this is gross man.
Like you,
you,
like,
you can't move through them.
Like I'm walking,
pulling my bags and like one after the other unit.
All right,
here.
I know,
right?
Sorry.
Under eyes are
holding up their fucking sign and it's like,
wow,
this is weird.
I'm uncomfortable here.
You realize like,
Whoa,
this is.
They're playing by different rules.
It's a third world country son.
You can call it canned coon.
All you want.
You just landed in a place where laws don't apply.
Everything's different mean.
Some laws apply,
but it's not the same.
You know,
everything's run by fucking violent drug gangs.
You know there's,
I mean they have a short.
They have a military presence.
Sure they have police,
but the fucking drug gangs in Mexico are.
They run every,
everything,
every spec in there near the border.
You go to the
even have our weapons.
They ended up busting them with our military weapons.
Is that when you realize how fucking nutty these government agents are,
did you hear about that?
What's it called?
Operation fast and furious.
It was like,
do you think we give it to them or they just end up.
Because we'd like to destabilize regions.
Oh,
100 percent.
We played both sides.
We,
we,
because guns turned up in El Paso to the guns.
They turned up in crimes that were used in El Paso,
so the guns that the atf sold to the Mexican drug traffickers,
those fucking guns showed up in our country,
so those,
those guns could have easily been used to kill Americans.
Civilians,
because our fucking government is completely incompetent and retarded.
Two thousand weapons were trafficked along the US Mexico border and many were
using violent crimes in Mexico and in addition to Ak 47,
semiautomatics involved in the program were recovered after a US border.
Agent was killed south of Tucson.
Wow.
A US fucking border agent was killed with one of these weapons.
So under the program dub fast and furious agents with the Federal Bureau of
Alcohol,
tobacco,
and firearms and explosives in the Phoenix field office allowed licensed firearm
dealers to sell weapons to illegal straw buyers in the hope that the agents
could track the weapons and arrest Mexican drug cartel leaders.
That was their walkie fucking dopey ass idea.
They were going to allow the fucking Mexican drug cartels to get more weapons.
Did they have gps things at home or something?
Then that kind of makes sense.
If you give a bunch of guns and you watched,
that's dumb.
They know where they are.
They already know where they are there.
Where the drug guys.
Are they a fucking ranches man?
These guys are to be bro.
Yo.
They have dollars.
So you never know.
Like there was a whole theory that they want to really like bankrupt Mexico.
Have you ever heard of the marrow?
You buy into that at all?
I heard about it,
yeah.
Like the whole thing was just.
We actually had it on CNN.
I think about just like how they're trying to like make like Mexico is broke as
shit and then America broke as shit and then bring down Canada with us and then
everything's.
Our money's worth.
Nothing that they just get rid of are.
It's the Amiro think that's possible.
Do you think that the government actually plots to crash the economy?
Absolute incompetence.
I don't think that they plot to crash shit.
I do think that the powers that be crashed,
the market so they can buy everything cheaper and then it goes up and they buy
more and
I definitely think that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well I definitely think that people short stocks and they manipulate the market
and do stuff like that to get kids to get money,
but those aren't.
That's not necessarily the same people that are the government.
These are,
this is people that are involved in the market.
The market sort of pays for the government to get the government to do certain
things their way that helped them and them and stealing money and make sure
there's a lot of clauses.
They get away a lot of shady shit completely legally,
but I don't think they're plotting.
Here's my theory over the,
you know,
the economy.
I think that's kind of.
You ever watched the first 48?
Yes.
You ever see somebody kill somebody over $20 worth of crack?
Yeah.
And you're like,
well those are just thugs and gals,
but they're people.
They're wired certain ways.
You're looking at the government,
you're looking at people who are dealing with tr billions,
if not trillions of dollars.
I just don't think they're going to let you know a flip of a coin to decide
where that money goes and that they could have some problem with manipulating
shit.
I'm not saying that's what happens,
but I would never ever put a pass somebody to manipulate something for a ton of
money.
Yeah,
maybe.
But you know what?
There's too many people would have to be involved in rigging the whole economy
to collapse and then you'd have to figure out who the hell's gonna profit on
this and then you'd have to follow the money.
Here's the,
the,
the.
There's no mystery why things collapsed.
There's no mystery.
There was a god damn money grab and they,
they knew that it was temporary and they went crazy and they made,
you know,
the,
the whole economy for Julie based on nothing based on nonsense,
but slowly but surely not least on gold up based on anything.
It's all based on craziness.
And then there's derivatives,
and I read this mat tie eeb article we just talking about the derivative economy
being like 100 times larger than the regular economy.
Whatever the fuck that means like it's it,
it gets so fucking squirrely.
So they,
they know what,
what went wrong.
It's not like someone's sabotage it on purpose so that they can profit from it
and that they could slowly devalue the dollar so they can combine the countries
together.
You know,
there's no profit in that man.
There's no,
there's no ultimate profit and creating one giant country.
There are.
I've listened.
I'm not saying.
I guess I would say that's the theory out there.
I'm not,
I the,
it's beyond,
but I wouldn't,
I wouldn't put it past anybody.
I mean you're talking about because when they do that,
supposedly what's going to have to happen,
and this is such a radical thing,
but it would be like you would scrap the constitution,
you'd have to scrap the constitution and have done that anyway.
They've sort of done that anyway.
Slowly but surely this will be a direct light parts of freedom of speech.
Parts of the Second Amendment,
the right to bear arms has been compromised significantly in this country and
more and more now that the,
the they were trying to do with the vapor,
with,
um,
medical marijuana,
they trying to make it so that if you have medical marijuana,
you're not allowed to possess a gun anymore or you're not a lot of buy a new
gun.
It's ridiculous.
They're there.
They're fucking with people's rights,
inalienable rights as non criminals in the United States of America,
as hunters,
as,
as people that want to go target shooting.
It's whatever you know you're saying because someone uses medical,
they shouldn't be allowed to.
What about oxycodone?
You got that on your list?
No,
you don't.
I'll go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
That's fucking criminals.
Like,
did she go to jail for that dude just for even suggesting that medical marijuana
should be something that you should lose your gun for and not oxycontin and
Vicodin and not a regular drinker.
Fuck you.
You going on your purse?
So transparent man,
that is one of the most transparent pieces of corruption the world has ever
seen.
The idea that the fucking atf is going to go after potheads before they go after
pharmaceutical companies.
Alcohol companies.
You're going to go after people who smoke pot.
They're the ones who can't have guns.
Well then what about Obama and his administration now trying to shut down all
the dispensary's?
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
It's a bag of goods.
It's all bullshit and they say it's the Department of Justice or say
I guess they're not listening to them.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't.
I don't know how that works.
I don't know how much.
Say the president really wants you.
I don't.
That's what I think happens is he got in there he wanted like,
yes,
we can get in there real.
It's all the bill Hicks whole thing.
They showed him a different fucking view of the Kennedy assassination.
It's even different than the bill Hicks joke.
It's like instead he thought he was going to go there and he was going to get
into an office and he was going to be able to change shit and when he got there,
there's a bunch of people feverously working to patch up a hole in the middle of
the universe and they're like,
listen,
this is what.
You can only keep this together for another fucking year or two and it's going
to blow.
It doesn't matter if the economy goes.
Doesn't matter if we get cancer.
This,
this is fucking thing's going to blow.
This is a,
there's a,
there's a hole in the universe.
We're trying to patch it up.
We've got our boys holding it down and they flew him out the fucking area.
Fifty one and Nevada and he looked at the whole university went fuck.
And then his hair slowly became gray.
What do you wanna go after pot after pot.
God,
what do you want?
Who Cares?
At this point in Pakistan?
Where with Pakistan?
Fuck it.
Why not?
Iran?
Iran as bombs.
Let's,
let's bomb them first fucking hole in the universe.
Well,
why not get gray quick?
Didn't,
well,
you know,
he looks better.
Most black don't crack,
that's for sure.
Because of the bush.
Oh yeah,
they do.
They didn't care because they started seeing shit that we don't even know about.
They're just like,
you hear what Bill Clinton said,
man.
One of the craziest things that he said about being in an office,
it was about the moon landings.
He said that when he was a kid just a couple of months after the Apollo 11
landing,
you know,
he said that it was amazing that man put a person on the moon and he worked with
his old carpenter.
Carpenter said that he thought that that was bs and that a television fellows,
because I don't believe a word of it,
those television fellers can try to get you to believe anything I don't believe
man landed on the moon.
And he said at the time I thought that guy was a crank.
He goes,
but after eight years in the White House,
just stop and think about that.
Who did he say after eight years in the White House?
I started to think maybe he was ahead of his time.
This is the fucking president the fucking president said that.
Just imagine the shit that he saw where he would even pretend that the moon
landings possibly could have been faked,
that he would even entertain that for a moment.
I don't think we have a goddamn clue as to what really creepy shit is going on
behind closed doors.
When the farmers who shopped pharmaceutical companies talk about the amount of
drugs that they produce every year that they need to sell and how they upped the
oxycontin every fucking year.
You know,
they've upped it so much since we've been in Afghanistan too.
What a coincidence.
Afghanistan producers,
all the heroin and that's where their fucking getting it and that's where they
make an oxycontin and we're over there protecting it 100 percent and it's so
funny that people don't believe any of that,
that,
that they can't sit there and as we told them,
that their leaders might not have their best interest.
Especially when you're talking about billions and billions and billions of
dollars when you're talking about just ridiculous sums of money.
We're willing,
we're willing to do some creepy shit.
We're willing to do some creepy shit,
man.
And they don't give a fuck man.
I always question authority,
man.
Always.
I just think it's more fun.
It's interesting.
Why keep,
make their jobs easier,
but look how easily they can justify what they do.
Like Obama had,
there was some fucking one of those speeches where they talked about,
uh,
you know,
where it was like Obama had jokes written for him,
and he had a joke about his daughters and he said,
I have a two words for you predator.
Drone.
Like he was joking,
people dating his daughter that he will send a Predator drone on you.
What's kind of a fucked up joke.
And then when you go look into how many people have died using Predator drones,
how many innocent people have done hundreds of them,
including like,
I think it was like 150 children.
So children,
small jokes.
One hundred and 50 children have been killed by things that are ultimately under
his control since he is the commander in chief of the United States army and the
United States military force.
Right?
He's the commander in chief.
Why don't you,
so ultimately he's at the top of the blame list.
A hundred and 50 babies were killed by missiles from a flying robot and he's
joking around about people dating his daughter.
One hundred percent and here's the whole.
I've said I'm using a predator.
Drones go after him,
but here's the thing,
it's back to hand to hand combat.
If you and I are going at it and you see I give up,
there's a sense of like,
okay,
he's giving up,
but if you're a thousand miles away,
you're not going to see me surrender.
And it means nothing.
There's no like the detachment.
It's the same kind of detachment you get on the Internet where you're allowed to
use like a fake name.
Like this guy could talk about training porn because he doesn't have to worry.
He's detached.
Or if someone could be mean to you and you know,
they don't worry about the social repercussions of being mean to you because
they don't say it was like a fuck.
You triple,
you fucking suck.
You will read my comments
against those or did you hear that?
The founder of Facebook,
his sister is trying to make it so people have to use their real names on the
Internet.
I don't know if it'll ever happen.
I don't like that.
I think you should be able do whatever you want.
If you want to use your real name,
your real name,
if you don't.
I think there should be places where you have to use your real name.
Like I my message board,
I would like it if you had your real face and your real name and that's what we
saw and that's you.
That's that can't make that happen.
I mean I guess I could,
but I don't.
I don't want to be censoring people and if that was the case,
people wouldn't be able to post shit because of what they do for a living.
Like there's some people that have asked me to change their screen names because
their screen name,
somebody from work found out their screen names,
so they asked me to change their screen name so that they couldn't get some
fucking tattle tattletale at work.
Couldn't go.
Yeah.
Bob's talking about tranny porn doesn't work.
Look at the times where he's logged on,
just 4:00 PM is working.
If we're talking about young people do that Shit,
man.
It's so much track tracking to nowadays,
like twitter,
facebook,
everything you post.
How many times have you used twitter would ask you use your location?
Yeah.
They want to use my,
the,
my latest phone.
Has that turned on immediately?
Like I didn't even do it and I'm like,
great.
Did I just like tweet?
Did you get a forecast?
Yeah,
yeah,
it has.
It has that shit on it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's creepy.
It is creepy.
I mean I just think people are.
I mean because there's no ramifications.
True.
And ultimately everything comes down to accountability.
That's what I think we get away from more and more in,
in this society,
especially in this country in which is,
you know,
my whole thing is I wish they would say that I occupy Wall Street or la is like,
you want accountability,
man.
You want accountability for everything you do.
You know,
whether it's government,
whether it's your personal,
you know,
actions.
It's accountability and that's what they're asking for.
But no one will come out and say that on that thing.
So they all put out there,
I fucked up and the whole thing's falling apart and no one's going to jail.
That's a.
that's.
That's a sure sign that the justice system is not working properly.
A sure sign that our elected leaders are not going after the people that had
created this problem.
100.
I gotTa stop saying that 100 percent,
1000 percent fighting I should say.
It's like a drinking game.
At this point.
People were drinking shots at this player,
shit faced.
Can you imagine in the future,
like if there was a movie that that was designed like prior,
like Avatar or something like that,
like Cgi and every time you wash it and going back to what you were talking
about earlier,
every time you watched it in a new partner,
a new scene was in the movie and it was created randomly buy a computer
generated kind of like minecraft.
This video that could be possible.
You could sit down and you can sit down and watch star wars,
like a whole new thing,
version of star wars.
Every time you watch it becomes like a choose your own adventure movie where
it's like different choices give you a different ending to the script.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely man.
The future is going to be very strange when it comes to what you can create,
artificial environments that you can create.
The real question to me is like,
what is gonna?
What's gonna?
When is it going to be human stupidity?
Or is it going to be technology?
It's like,
it's almost like there's a race to a final conclusion.
Theology maybe,
but we're also invading Pakistan and Iran has got nukes and fucking with the
large Hadron collider and some new laser they're proposing to build in Britain
that could punch a whole new space time and that
this is a weird race going on and at the same time,
you know,
can you go again?
So,
so look what's going on in the Congo,
look what's going on in Mexico.
Look what's going on.
So many different parts of the world where human lives are just falling apart.
Human civilization falling apart,
chaos,
you know,
just ultimate chaos.
You look at like watch like documentaries on parts of Africa and you would swear
this is a post apocalyptic vision.
Things they do like just hacking or just to get there.
I mean,
it's crazy eating the flesh of innocent children on the enemy side to,
to,
to be little vulnerable and battle some of the stuff that I watched
documentaries on Liberia.
They've stained my brain forever,
man.
Cannibalism,
rampant,
rampant cannibalism.
You know,
we're going to have Shane Smith on the podcast from vice tv.
Um,
he's one of the guys who went to Liberia and uh,
who's the other guy went to North Korea to.
Yeah,
he's gone everywhere.
But this mother fucker me about that.
Recently they just watched me.
I can't wait to have this guy on.
I'm fucking so fired up.
He's,
he's been everywhere.
He was just in Beirut and he's,
he's traveling.
He travels all over the world,
the darkest parts of the world.
He says he has to get new passports all the time because he brings his passport,
the fuck Iraq,
Afghanistan,
like,
what are you doing?
And he's like,
I'm a reporter,
you know?
And then they're like,
for what?
He's like,
VBS and they're like CBS.
no.
VBS.
Like the fuck is vbs.
So he just,
whenever we go somewhere dark,
it just gets a new passport.
You're better off telling me about his one in North Korea and how crazy it is.
Yeah.
Well he said he's got some North Korea.
He said N K slay footage.
I didn't even know what that meant,
but in the Internet schooled me,
North Korea Douche.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
People are like,
you seriously?
They don't know what it is.
I didn't know.
I started trying to think of what that meant.
I never associated North Korea with slaves for some reason.
I didn't think that there would be slaves.
Dude,
I guarantee you that happens more and more common,
you know.
And that's a whole thing about,
you know,
this whole free trade where they moved their businesses over these third world
and your phone off the table.
Everybody take your phone off the table,
everybody keeps lowering lowering prices.
Eventually the Labor is going to be to the point where they don't even want pay
for Labor to keep the prices so low.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
look,
we're willing to do that to dolphins.
Yeah.
Why Not Chinese people?
I don't understand that either.
You know?
I mean,
that's,
that's really helpful.
If you ever go to China,
you'll have the best time ever.
China is the shit.
What'd you do in China?
I did stand up really idea.
It was the best time.
I mean Steve Byrne or Steve Byrne and I,
we went to Beijing.
Shanghai loved it.
What did you perform to American expats?
How many people were in the crowd?
A different shows are different sizes.
All white people in the crowd or do some Chinese people?
Everything.
Really everything.
What was the percentage of white people?
Chinese people.
Well,
at our shows it was very high.
It was like mostly white people.
It was like 80 percent white.
Wow.
You know,
but it was the,
it was amazing.
Really.
I had such great to nicest people
ever.
Chinese are the nicest people ever and you know,
you just learn.
It's like everybody's the same and she,
she got governments and they're fighting with each other over resources.
The resources problem in China's.
It's really a problem.
You is a funny thing.
That whole factory thing in China.
You know when people.
I had a thing on the podcast were I was trying to figure out,
is there a Karma free cell phone,
his cell phone that I can get where I don't feel bad about owning it?
Turns out there's not.
Why do you feel bad about owning it?
I feel bad that someone has to make fucking fifteen cents an hour to make
something.
They should have an iphone called the Karma and the icon has made in America and
they pay the people a real wage and you're going to cost twice as much.
It costs twice as much and a lot of people would folk you do sugar,
brilliant food.
My phone.
No,
who are you fucking go to me.
That's not what I'm saying,
dude,
I'm not talking about you if you want to.
I'm not judging you,
but I'm saying it would be nice for me if I knew that this was made by people
who were paid for their labor,
you know,
a really fair price so they could afford to go on vacation so they could afford
to live in a nice place so they can afford to have food.
And you know,
I think if you fucking work all day,
you should not have issues.
You should not have issues.
Like,
uh,
you know,
I'm homeless.
You know,
you should not have issues.
Like,
oh,
I can't afford health insurance.
You should not.
If you're working all day,
your,
your day should be worth something.
Well,
and that's why I think the whole thing is going to collapse because not just in
America,
but around the world because here you're taking these jobs from here where
you're paying a living wage and you're taking over here and you're not paying a
living wage or paying next to nothing.
So the people over here can't buy anything and now the people over here can't
buy anything.
So who's going to buy the goods?
Well,
the real question is,
yeah,
who can buy it,
but the real question is how can you compete,
how can you make something in this chair of support and that's why the
administration just same three new huge free trade agreements they say are as
big as Nafta and they're going around like job creating bill on that and you
just sign that,
that free trade thing.
We're screwed.
Map and stuff like that is where people really get the motivation.
That's the,
the,
the inspiration to think that this is a rigged system to think that this is some
sort of Illuminati plan to slowly crashed the economy.
Things like that,
you know,
free trade agreements.
But I think it's just a fucking money grab.
It's just greedy corporations,
corporations and greedy cons.
And the problem is the corporations,
they found out that the Chinese and all these different industries,
nations all around the world are willing to work harder,
longer hours for less money and then thus they can produce shit cheaper.
And because they found out that it's like,
they're like,
well,
we have to compete if you want these American jobs,
you know,
our whole business is going to go under unless you move or at least our
factories over there.
And then,
okay,
move your factories over there but sell your Nike's over here,
you know,
you gotta have some Nike employees over here,
but,
you know,
right.
One hundred percent.
And over there it's like,
I guess the stuff's cheap or to sell in terms of like,
you know,
what Chinese are buying the same goods as us.
We pay way more because we supposedly have a higher standard of living.
But eventually that's going to have to go down to.
Right.
I mean if we're not having those jobs and we're all working at Walmart making
like $7 an hour,
we can't afford to buy a,
a,
you know,
$150 phone or something.
You eat any wacky shit.
When you were in China,
did you any bugs or anything?
No,
they had squirrel on,
um,
one of,
one of the restaurants.
I just didn't want to eat it.
Pretty normal here.
What's that?
Did you sleep with any of them?
Know?
I banged a Israeli chick in China,
in China,
and she was.
Was she doing over there?
She's,
she was trying to start it.
She was working for some company and she to stablish some kind of a,
you know,
she had a business over there.
People go over there.
It's like the wild west or moving there.
They're trying to set up businesses and you know,
it's awesome though man.
But what they did in China,
someone was saying something bad ass about that,
but moving to another country,
wes bro.
It's like your reality just completely shifted.
You know,
you move into moving to fucking Hawaii.
It's Kinda crazy,
you know.
But God damn man,
moving to China,
I had the best time and the driving is crazy.
They'll turn anything into a car.
I,
they're totally racist.
The Chinese,
they don't give a shit.
They're totally racist.
I used to,
when I was there,
I had a full beard.
I looked Middle Eastern.
They don't like middle easterns because they think they're all drug dealers
there.
So I couldn't get a car,
sometimes a taxi,
so the only guy that would pick us up one time was this dude who drew,
drove what looked like they took a hot dog vending machine and turned it into a
car and it literally had like the most chunkiest like shift,
changing device and I'm,
you'll never scream more in your life like a little girl then when you drive
through China through Beijing or Shanghai because they don't follow the lights.
I've seen somebody try and Chinese traffic accidents online.
You don't have to convince me.
I've seen people get run over by cars in China.
You.
Oh,
what about that little girl?
I couldn't watch it.
It just makes me sad.
That's the overpopulation thing,
man.
When you had.
It's just like they've done population density studies on rats and the same
thing happens.
You get too many in one place and they devalue each other.
You know,
that's what's going on,
man.
You can't jam that many fucking human beings in one spot and expect everybody to
think that everybody is precious because he's precious.
Things were my fucking way,
you know,
so no one cares,
man.
Yeah.
It's just.
I remember reading that in a college man.
They started running in gangs.
They said like one guy was,
you know,
they had.
Yeah,
it got really shady,
like rats.
Just mental problems.
Just.
Yeah.
They,
uh,
some of them huddled in the corner,
the rats,
they would huddle huddle in the corner and just rock themselves back and forth,
back.
Just going nuts.
Now you look at some,
some human behavior and you've got to go,
God damn.
How the fuck can we ever prevent this?
What the hell happened here?
What,
what is this?
You
know what?
I was watching this.
I tweeted this,
this video about this woman who was a pioneer in scat porn.
It's uh,
it's rough.
And if you read my tweets,
read it,
but don't click on the link.
There's a lake nearby choice.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
She's one of the first while she's,
you know,
she's an expert at it.
She's,
that's what she does,
but she eats shit.
She eats it and swallows it.
And she was talking about how she loves being stuffed with Shit.
Dude,
it's.
I would love to have her on my podcast.
Like I want to interview those people.
She's in Germany,
she's.
She speaks German.
I would love Germany this video.
But Dude,
she has a website.
Somebody tweeted the websites,
I retweeted it.
If you see the retweet,
don't click it.
I'm telling you right now,
don't do it because this woman is just smeared and shit and these videos and she
has people shit in her mouth.
And she chose it and swallow it.
And they asked her how many,
how much shit you think you've eaten over the course of your life.
She was like,
oh,
several bathtubs full.
Well,
what about the guy that used to go on sterner lake to get thrown up on?
That's nothing,
dude.
She.
This bitch has eaten bathtubs full of human shit.
Someone let's get thrown up on you.
Them Shits were some throw off fucking.
They're both equally bad.
We watched it way worse than when we did open anthony.
We were there for the infamous baby bird.
It was me and Ari were.
There you weren't there for baby bird when the guy threw up the guy's mouth.
This fucking dude,
I forget.
That's right there bro.
From Inaki.
No,
not pat.
Yeah,
pat from when Nike.
But the other Guy Smith.
What the fuck's his name?
Pat Duffy.
Pat Duffy was the other guy who let them throw up and its mouth.
So this was a,
there was a eggnog eating contest and I don't remember how many shots you have.
It was something insane.
He's almost a gallon I think.
I think the human body can only have a gallon of milk or two gallons.
It was like 70 shots or something like that.
Something insane.
So anyway,
he does that.
And then the,
uh,
we were trying to figure out what to do because he knew he was gonna throw up.
And then we suggested that one of the interns lean his head over the dumpster,
over the garbage bucket and open his mouth and let the dude throw up in his
mouth like a baby bird feed.
Not that guys.
Now where is he?
Where's that guy?
Right.
He did a bunch of other shit too.
He,
he,
he brushed his teeth with dog shit.
You're all in,
in that open anthony world at that point.
That's where you're going to be working and that's where you're going.
You can't go.
It's like the girl got shit on.
It's like it's gonna be hard for her.
She didn't choose to get shit on yet,
but she's still going to be the girl that got shit on him.
Is this Pat Duffy guy?
Well that's crazy.
I'm with crazy.
Where do you go if you're pat?
There's those guys out there,
man.
This guys out there that are run to me and put me on fucking fear factor,
Bro.
You anything.
You know there's,
there's a few of those guys that just,
they're willing to do it.
Look,
jackass guys that are willing to do anything for the joke,
you know,
did fucking Johnny Knoxville stood in front of a bull with a blindfold on?
He really did.
He really did that.
He's a goddamn movie star.
Okay.
He was in a movie with the Rock Sky,
stood in front of a bull with a blindfold on and let bowl launch
him through the air like a,
like a sheet.
Steevo did the last movie completely sober because I knew back in the day there
are popping Vic's and just bang killers so they couldn't feel.
He did this one completely sober.
I'm like,
that's some crazy ass shit,
man.
God,
it's horrible.
Yeah.
Well maybe he broke his nose on the.
The roast.
Yeah.
He ran into Mike Tyson's fist.
He's the nicest guy,
man.
I just feel like.
I guess that's the thing that Mike Tyson break his nose.
His whole thing is he does stents.
That's not a stunt dude a stunt.
It's cutting yourself.
Jump a motorcycle and you land it and everybody cheers.
That's not a stunt.
That's like saying,
I'm going to drive my motorcycle into a wall.
It's a stunt stunt.
You're crashing.
You're hurting yourself.
I've done that.
You have?
Yeah.
My spike shell.
That's right.
Oh,
that's right.
That was a fun show,
right?
It was.
You kicked cope and Ellis.
Yeah.
Jason Alice.
What did you guys do?
Just did it?
Average jackass type shit?
Uh,
well yeah.
I mean later on because I never really watched Jack Ass,
but later on I watched the show.
I'm like,
oh,
they got that from that.
They Kinda,
it was Kinda like Taj Point.
Oh,
meets Jack Ass.
That was the premise of the show.
And um,
yeah,
I did some crazy shit man that like the worst thing was was uh,
we had to make a sandwich.
Why people,
why the other guys were like eight feet away with paintball guns and we had
nothing on and we were just getting shot by paintball guns and I would feel bad
and I would like do it slowly.
Those guys didn't give a fuck.
They were vicious,
they were savages,
blah,
blah.
I'm getting nailed it.
It was the first time I want to quit the show.
I was like,
I'm done dude.
Fuck this show.
I never want to do.
I didn't even know were doing stunts on the show.
I just thought I got hired to talk shit about videos and that's what I'm good
at.
I could just tell when did the stunts become a part of the show?
Well,
the next day I show up.
They're like,
okay,
you got the Gig.
I'm like,
oh,
cool.
That's great.
Okay.
I got gotta show on Spike.
I show up and goes,
here's what you're going to be doing.
I'm like,
what?
Because I didn't,
they didn't,
never mentioned that in the audition and I got it through going with Steve
Byrne.
He never mentioned that.
And you can't say no,
but yeah,
I need to get on television that point,
you know,
so it's like fuck it.
That's how you felt.
You felt like you had to say yes,
right?
I,
yeah,
I mean I'm close.
I love spike.
I was,
you know,
it was cool chiller.
You didn't want to do it right.
You didn't want to do it.
You didn't think that's what you're going to do.
But once you got there like I need this fucking TV show.
Yep.
Wow.
They,
I was headlining clubs when I got it and make a big difference if the clubs and
shit like that.
Yeah,
I was,
I was headlining clubs.
Did you ever try to do something else like that again?
Do you ever try it?
I would never do a show again.
Really?
Yeah.
So when I was canceled,
you were happy.
Uh,
even though you're off tv,
you were happy now.
I wasn't happy so it wouldn't do it again.
They called up again.
If it continued then I would have done it,
but I wouldn't do it now if they call me back.
Hey,
we're gonna do another show.
I wouldn't do it.
Have you seen shock fights?
Uh,
Jason Analysis?
No.
This is some
shit.
I don't know where the fuck is happening.
I don't know.
It looks like it's in Cuba.
I don't know who came up with this,
but there's these guys in a ring and they have fucking fist.
They have things on their fists that are electrocuting each other like tasers on
their knuckles,
but they're punching each other with tasers.
That's a guy knocks a guy out with a fucking taser in his hand.
It's bad ass.
It's crazy.
They're throwing kicks and
yeah,
he was dog collars.
The crowd just zap them.
He's willing to do some stuff that I don't understand,
but this shock fights is like,
man,
how?
How far are we from throwing a dude with a sword into an arena with a lion?
How far away?
It's not that I'm sure in third world countries is going to happen sooner than
you think because there was a.
There was a thing where a guy was going to have a fucking sword fight.
There was a,
I think it was the guy going to fight a lion.
It was a Greek guy or something like that.
I forget what the whole story was,
but I was like,
I remember this thing,
like it was either a sword fight or he's going to fight an aunt,
a wild animal or something like that,
but I remember thinking like,
okay,
this is how it starts.
Because it starts where people hear about on the Internet and then they go,
oh,
okay.
And then somewhere,
wherever the fuck it is,
where life's not that expensive.
High Tiawana.
Somewhere along those lines,
they set up an arena and they just say,
well,
instead of both sides,
now we're going to have people wearing armor and they're gonna fight lions and
I'm rooting for the line every time.
Wow.
Maybe how do you not?
Maybe the guy has children who can't feed and he's fucking willing to get in
there with a lot of line.
Has No choice.
Yeah,
and being sure.
I mean the guy has a choice,
but I still root for the person.
I'm reminded lying people.
I'm on team lying,
Bro.
I have to,
man.
I just like the lines aren't choosing to be there.
He's not,
but he's going to kill the person.
It's not like the person that was any different than the killer.
Well,
that's are dumb.
Lions aren't smart.
It's not that much different,
but lions are not that.
You know,
lions are just fucking there to remove mental capacity,
whether it's going to be a crime or not.
Not only that,
I feel like lions are part of our domain,
whereas killer whales,
we have to go into their world and pull them out of their world and cap.
They don't interact with us on a regular basis unless we get on boats and enter
into their world.
Lions.
On the other hand,
they want.
You mean you're in Africa like they.
A friend of mine was in Africa and while he was there,
some guy got killed where they.
It came into the camp.
The lion came into the camp while the dude was in the fucking shower and dragged
him out of the shower to female lions.
Lions can suck my Dick.
Okay.
Lions can go fuck themselves.
It's a killer whale.
Like guys,
surfing,
kill comes up and whoop some ass.
I don't.
They don't.
They don't know.
No one's been killed by Carol.
Well,
not only that,
they help people.
They've actually saved people when they've learned they're drowning.
Killer whales aren't sharks.
The sharks.
I could see your point.
Sharks can suck my dick.
You can take a shark and throw in a fish tank all day long.
I don't have a feeling for a sharp,
but killer whales are superintelligent safe people.
But I think that when you're,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not saying you should have Christians versus the lions.
I'm not saying you should pick an arm dudes and send them in and you know,
have a sword fight
with the lions.
But I am saying if it goes down,
I'm rooting for the fucking person.
I think I want to know,
can you kill a lion with a sword?
Can you be armored up and kill a fucking line with nothing but a sword?
If that guy can do it,
good for him,
man.
I just might not be able to.
You might not be able to line.
Might just Jack you every time.
It's like you want to dudes from death row fighting to the death.
I'm fine with that.
Really just fighting it an animal.
I just don't,
you know,
it's like I get,
I get.
I don't think you should do it.
Yeah.
If you do do it,
I'm rooting for the person and then I will put 20 bucks and I'm always going for
the lie.
Really?
I'm always.
Was that Brian?
Same.
Same exact reasons.
But what if you found out the guy was like super poor and you have the Guy
Brian?
No,
I just no sleep.
Why is it black?
It looks under the thing like you just got rocked and your eyeball.
That's the.
It's coming out of his eyeballs.
He had fun.
While I agree with Sam on that,
I think.
I think even if they showed me the story of this poor,
sad guy,
he has a choice to chose the choice to fucking line on it,
but I'm rooting for him and we might not interfere with whales because we
haven't moved there yet.
But if you went,
came,
went back thousands and thousands of years.
We're in lion territory right now,
you know,
so I'm sort of.
I mean there was some sort of big cats here.
Saber Tooth Tigers I think.
Yeah,
I think there was lions.
Well actually there was,
there was a North American line a long fucking time ago.
So a different commands welcome through the jungle and a lion comes.
I'm rooting for the guy.
Okay,
But when you grabbed the lion,
you have very specific rules in line to be there with no choice where it's not
naturally going to be there and it could die because you're.
You're trying to make 20.
It's like,
it's like why people didn't like the dog fighting.
Especially when you have a dog.
You're like,
I said,
dude,
I'm not saying you should do it,
but I'm saying if you do do it,
I'm going to root for you.
I'll smack it.
Animal though.
I'd not heard it though.
Just you've got discipline your dog.
We slept at him.
See the woman who heads it like a hippo for a pet.
Oh my God.
I read some article on it.
She has a hippo for pack.
It's going to come and get ya.
It's eventually going to turn on you.
Is it a male?
I didn't.
I didn't read it.
Whether it was a male or a female.
She can keep it together for a little while.
If it's a male,
it's going to be biting people in half.
They bite crocodiles and half to 100.
I'm 100 percent.
Was is 100 percent.
No,
no man.
I'm just agreeing with you.
What'd you get on your testing?
Me One hundred percent.
You a plus student?
No.
From this weekend you're in La Hoya.
If people want to go see you at the comedy store when you work with down there.
I'm working with uh,
Steve Simone.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
And Tony Hinchcliffe.
They just had a couple gigs fall out.
I was supposed to be in sale,
but then I'm going to be December first.
We're going to have the naughty show at the comedy store.
Powerful change.
Joe Rogan should make a return.
Can't go.
Sorry.
We can do it.
Good luck.
And Satan's asshole.
Yeah,
I could do it,
but I'm not going to.
Good luck.
Are you one?
I don't ever need to go back to that.
You don't.
There's no win contests.
You know what one is
the art form of comedy one,
but the comedy store absolutely fucking picked the wrong side so they can go
fuck themselves.
Fucked up,
I like the laugh factory.
I just that places you have a problem with that place.
Oh,
100 percent doing naughty comedy now.
Then the Improv is awesome.
I love the
job.
I felt it was better for my act anyway.
I feel like the comedy store is so dark and angry that I think a lot of that
shaped.
My material's changed.
Braille hasn't really.
And I don't mean that to be like,
it's different.
It's not like you leaving.
Was it changed really?
Yeah.
Now it's much like pricing.
I mean like it's not the same as it used to be.
What was it like?
What's the difference?
It's a,
I think it's like the acts aren't,
you know,
I used to watch,
monsters onstage,
just guys who are like,
fuck man,
I don't see that as much anymore.
It's not what it used to be.
There's a couple of young guys I think are bringing it,
but it's not,
you know,
it's like,
it's now a TV credit land.
How did that,
how did it make that change?
Um,
I don't know,
man.
I think it's weird how they use the same people over and over again.
Yeah.
But now they have.
They've definitely opened the door but just seems like I've gotten there on some
nights where these people are in the main room at 8:00 on like a Wednesday or
Thursday or whatever.
And I'm saying this person sucks so bad.
He shouldn't even be in the belly room.
And he's in the main stage.
Really.
The problem is that what,
what made that place great and it was never perfect,
but what made it great was that you could be somebody who was an unknown and you
could get up on stage there and start honing your craft.
Those days are done.
You know,
there's certain things going on there were like,
apparently if you're on Chelsea lately,
you know,
that's a sign that you've arrived and you see like a lot of people who do that
panel now in the lineup and that's a great show and she's done great for like
blowing up some of my friends,
but that doesn't necessarily mean you're going to crush in that our which has
its own Voodoo.
You know,
so nothing wrong with putting people that are coming up,
but you got to put them in between some really good talent and the problem is
they have some talent that really doesn't work anywhere else.
They have some people there that can't get spots anywhere,
but they're grandfathered in somehow and they've got jokes that are literally 30
years old.
I mean there's some,
there's some people that tell some jokes and you haven't seen them in a decade
and then they'll go through the act the same fucking way and you know,
they don't get that many spots,
you know,
because there's a gang of them so they don't put them up every week,
but they'll put them up like every two weeks or every three or four weeks.
And you would sit there and you'd see them at.
Some of them would be like bitter and shit and I'm thinking there's something
wrong with these young kids and they suck and you know,
our generation was better and you're like,
God,
you're an Indian.
You're not even really a fucking comedian.
Do you understand this?
Yeah,
I do see that.
I see that lot.
I said we're to like the other waitresses.
It used to be waitresses,
uh,
you know,
only girls,
waitresses.
Now there's girls and guys.
It's just like the whole,
the whole thing is just the
waitresses are hot to the gay guys and gay guy and two,
they want some candy too,
Bro.
Gay Guys Want Candy.
That's what you guys have waiters.
While you can look at the waitress.
Do you have to fuck them all?
Brian?
Yes.
Brian,
have you tried to fuck any of the waitresses?
Not yet.
Brian is in a committed relationship.
SORTA kinda right now.
How's that going?
Is it all working out?
Stinky feet.
She's a very nice girl.
I have not even been home in two days because you're setting up that place for
the last three days straight.
Well,
why don't you come and crash your pad.
I crashed out in the studio.
You come over for like,
I took naps there for like an hour or two now I'd wake up and there's Jake
Nicole back door.
You Jagan colback Jordan.
You trying to steal your chick and Sam Tripoli is so deep deep in the world of
porn.
I'm not really,
if you say the full name,
I guess if everybody knows that he knows her,
he knows,
but there's 500,000 people that don't,
but you,
you're so deep into the winter.
Love Jadah with it.
Just go with it.
That's true.
Who knows?
More porn stars and you,
you're in that world.
People think I'm going to pop the porn whisper.
I'm really not.
I'm not really like know a lot of the man.
You get them to come on your naughty shows all the time,
but he's never seen the show.
What's the website?
Well,
it's coming back up.
It's been redesigned right now,
but to naughty comedy show.com and best way to get ahold of use what Sam triply
on twitter,
twitter,
Sam aaa on facebook or my email.
But you're,
uh,
those,
those are fucking,
those are fun shows.
He's got these naughty shows or just he's got a bunch of really good comedians,
but he's also got video clips and they do games.
They fuck around with the audience and they always have porn stars who do
things.
I don't know what they do.
They do their appearances and they show up and you know what,
they're people.
You know what man,
I know it sounds crazy and like they are who they are,
but at the end of the day they're really not that different than comedians and
if you really sat down and you had a conference that you'd be like,
wow,
that's exactly what comedians do.
They just have something that's kind of more taboo in society thing guys and you
know,
most of them are just straight business people.
They're like,
well that's sort of how they justified doing it too.
They sort of go into this business mode and that always weirds me out.
Like there's two types of porn stars.
There's like the,
the,
the flight.
It doesn't know any better.
Super Hot Pornstar.
It just gets worse because she saw and then there's a super ambitious career
woman porn star.
Yeah.
Those,
those kind of.
Those kind of get me in a weird way like,
wow,
this is a strange,
a strange animal.
Like this person is working hard to create all this porn and the real focus.
If you can blow up and you think podcasting is saturated,
porn is saturated.
There's A.
Everybody's a porn star.
Nobody's making money in it.
How many porn stars are there?
I mean there's more.
Probably at a seven now.
I think
porn stars in Comedians in La.
I would.
I wouldn't doubt it.
Just the camping thing alone.
When you find out that like check this out.
I don't know if you knew
this.
If you're.
If you're 18 years old and you need money,
you.
There is a way to block the whole state you live in,
so like say like if you live in California,
you block California and you can block certain cities and then you can cam where
you can make like fucking whatever,
$5 a minute,
$10 a minute and you have these things where you have like 20 people in the same
room and they're all chipping in more and more for you to stay in these rooms
and these girls are making thousands a night from just sitting on their fucking
ass masturbating and doing nothing.
But that's.
It's like it's basically sits taking advantage of the whole,
like primal caveman girl,
female relationship.
It's like when you go to a strip club and the stripper makes icon,
she does all the stuff that if you're at a normal club that lets the girl know
that she's interested in you so you make moves,
so they do all that.
They trick you and all that Shit and all they want you to do is by lap dances
from.
Oh,
that's the weirdest thing.
Most strip clubs with the roles are reversed and we men who've never been or
don't usually go,
they don't know how to deal with it.
You get there and all of a sudden the women are pursuing you and are super
aggressive about it.
Like,
well you want to.
Well you want to dance.
So for a lot of guys they just melt and like fall into it and next thing you
know that broke because the whole dynamic has just been shifted and they don't
understand like they're,
they're not.
They haven't built up a resistance for it.
They don't have the immune system for a strip club social immune system.
That's the whole thing about the naughty show is just like,
I like to explore that side of the world now.
It's not just sexual either.
It just like.
I like the crazier side of life and just like what makes everybody different and
stuff that everybody wants,
that everybody does in the shadows.
It's like a lot of people are doing it.
Why is they one talking about it and not that I don't like sex out in the open.
I mean meaning like I don't think porn star should be like Oscar award winners.
I don't.
I don't think.
I think everybody has their place,
but I don't think it's something you should have to be ashamed of where like
some find something out about you and now you're like the town like,
well,
you're just so used to it to most men,
the last thing they want is evidence that the woman has fucks some other dude,
not just fucks some other dude,
but he went asked to mouth on her and shot a load up her nose.
Oh,
well that's a whole.
That's a whole different thing.
You're talking about
guys who date porn stars.
I'm just saying that you know,
you don't judge them if you don't judge them or if you met a girl and then she
wanted a day and then you found out that she was a porn star.
Fuck,
hey judge.
Well if that's not what you're into.
Again,
if you're not into it,
you're like,
fuck.
Yeah,
but that's nothing.
You could do it.
Could you date a porn star?
It depends on the porn star.
Then what she did.
So stupid hot.
Depends on what you do.
She came home smelling like loads.
Then I couldn't do that,
but you know,
he dated a girl who does lesbian porn and like lesbos stuff's okay.
Right.
Which is a weird thing,
but I can also see where like,
you know,
some like aiden who is married to Bella,
Donna,
he's cooled watching her just get.
I don't think she doesn't anymore,
but she just getting my brother
cool.
I think even the guys that say it's not cool is still.
I think there's guys who are into that.
It is cool.
It's not cool
guys that are into.
I'm not saying everybody's into it.
I think people evolved,
man,
and sometimes they just look what guys go to prison.
They all of a sudden develop a desire to fuck man.
You know why?
Because they evolve,
they adapt,
they adapt to the situation and if the only way you can get a check like Bella,
Donna is to lead black guy's coming her ass.
You Go,
all right,
let's do this.
But that's from your perspective.
I totally understand.
But he may be into.
I'm just saying,
could be yes,
but could be.
That's the only one that's been around forever.
That's true too.
Yeah.
That's guys and just enjoy watching their girls get rocked by monsters.
Buddy of mine said that he met this girl at a party and she was really hot and
she was coming on to him and then all the sudden this dude came over and
introduced himself as the husband and the guy's like,
oh,
what the fuck?
And the guy was like,
no man,
it's cool.
It's cool.
It's cool that we swing.
And he was like,
oh wow.
He goes,
if I didn't have a couple of drinks in me,
I would have never done this.
Next thing you know,
they're in this outside patio and this chick is blowing him.
While the husband gives instructions to husband.
It was giving instructions.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Maybe this guy's black too.
Maybe it's just a black guys in white women and white husbands.
Zorba the COC holding thing.
A lot of the issues like black men and white guy,
like white guys,
like black men to fuck their wives because they think it's like this,
like really like degrading kind of thing.
Like sexually.
They're like,
Ooh,
that's so dirty.
You know?
He was like saying,
okay,
make them come.
Make them come.
Make them come in your mouth.
And he's like,
he goes,
part of me just wanted to get up and run away,
but it was two legs.
I was drunk and this girl was already blown me and he goes to the was hot.
If the girl wasn't hot,
he would have just given up.
But it was just one of those like,
what am I doing?
The guys like rub his balls,
Roosevelt,
and he's like,
well,
I got this dude,
you know,
I'm good.
We don't need your help.
We don't need any help.
She can blow me,
but you can't.
You can't talk back.
When I lived in Vegas,
that was like,
I,
I was at this one casino and they tried to pick me up.
They were swingers.
Oh.
They're like,
Hey,
what's up?
What's up?
This girls hitting on me.
Was she hot?
Yeah,
she was vegas hot,
but like kind of slutty back then.
I love that shit.
I will now.
What am I talking about?
I'm not judging it now I'm into like a librarian.
I'm in the whatever brother.
So,
uh,
yeah.
And I'm like,
what are you going to do,
coach?
Are you going to sit in the corner yelling out plays?
I can handle that shit.
Just be weird to hump.
Have somebody else's watching.
You could handle that.
If a guy was knowing that I couldn't,
couldn't.
Yeah.
But I've had threesomes like the dirt devil threesome where it's like you and
your buddy railing,
a chick given that's a buddy that's not a guy's husband or girl's husband
rather.
Yeah.
He's not sitting there judging and given me scores and calling out play.
I just think the moment you come,
you would just want to run away so badly.
You know?
The postnet syndrome effect would be so hard.
The depression that must just.
How many women will never understand this,
but there's many times in a man's life where your will convince you that this is
what you should be doing and then you know that she's Kinda gross or you're kind
of gross.
So the situations gross or she shouldn't be doing it,
but somebody that you're like,
yeah,
let's fucking do this.
And then when you come to the realization that you've been tricked,
there's nothing in the world like it.
It really.
It's a terrifying feeling.
It's like all of a sudden you have woken up in the middle of a reality that
you've created while you were under a trade quantum leap.
You're just like,
okay,
what's the situation here?
Where they just do well,
it's like you wrote wake up for,
you know,
I do a bit about how you like,
it's like you're normal,
you're driving your life until you have a hard on.
Then when you have a heart on,
it's like just sitting in the back seat of a really long bus.
Some other dude is driving it.
That's what it's like.
And you're like,
where do we go?
What the fuck are we doing?
Where are we going?
And then when,
when you come,
all of a sudden you wake up and you're at the front of the bus holding the wheel
again.
Like,
oh,
okay,
now I gotta get myself out of this fucking mess in here.
You Dick.
One hundred percent.
Oh God.
There when I said it again.
You did it again.
Herea background.
We're going to wrap this bitch up.
Where are you going?
Brian?
Got a little girl's bladder.
He's
A.
Yeah.
So that's such an interesting cat,
isn't he?
He is just telling you I can't follow things.
He doesn't.
And it's very interesting.
We have a podcast.
I,
I know how excited Brian is about the gas by how interactive he is if he's not
talking to the guests,
which makes me nervous right now because he hasn't talked at all a while.
I've been here,
but we've both been chatting up a storm and Qa,
chatty Cathy's here.
But uh,
it was like he just sits there quietly,
like,
come on and be interactive with me,
Dude.
And he's like,
no,
I always got to have a girl.
It's almost like bring me to a beast.
You always got to have a girl in the room and when you bring a girl then he's
more interactive.
Oh,
100.
you can tell if he likes the porn star.
He won't even let me talk.
Cuts me.
Obviously with running.
And this is why Brian is so fucking interested in podcasting is because all of a
sudden it's put him in contact with all these freaks.
Right.
Do you remember when I did that he supply,
even though I met both of the girls I've dated off the podcast.
It's sort of,
but you know,
but you met the first one through comedy
when I did the,
your podcast the first time and he was talking about how he thought podcasting
was a new casting couch and we both laughed at him and then it's true.
It's like,
you know,
you can,
you can work that to get some chicks here.
Like,
Hey,
I'm,
well that's the thing about a lot of porn stars.
They're looking to promote their shit.
They were looking to promote like weekends at clubs,
just like a comedian is,
you know,
when they go on the road,
like Brian went on the robos girl and he's like,
it's just like a comic.
Like you go and you have shows and you know,
you get paid and the club owners kind of a Dick.
It's like all the same,
best,
same shit.
First date of dating a porn star usually goes.
So do you have any html skills?
You,
they try to get you to do their websites,
their websites.
Now I've always found the girls have somebody in their life who runs all that
stuff.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
they,
they take some guy who they know is not going anywhere and that guy will start
managing them and taking them on the road and,
you know,
be their bodyguard and hold their money and make sure the guys can't finger them
when they're up.
They're
sticking their asshole on their face because that's what it is.
I started taking martial arts of Brian and Brian had to go,
hey,
no finger in guys.
Come on,
come on with dirty fingernails or buttle freckles this weekend,
this Friday night.
Um,
it will be me and Duncan at the comedy and magic show comedy and magic club and
her mostly beach,
California.
There's two shows.
Seven and 9:30.
Yes,
seven.
I know.
Ridiculous.
But that's how they roll and foremost would be that headroom community.
My buddy wants to get you out in Santa Barbara or Santa Barbara was he got up
there a couple of clubs.
They want us to comedy clubs.
No one's a rock club.
In other words,
the theater.
He's always,
you know,
he wanted to hit up your age and try to see if you can get.
Yeah,
give me his information.
I'll.
Yeah,
I'll go to Santa Barbara.
It's not that far.
Yup,
I'll do that.
He's a great guy too.
Okay,
cool.
That's no further for me.
That Ontario.
Yeah,
I'll go that way.
Santa Barbara.
Just the opposite way.
Yeah.
Santa Barbara's fucking beautiful.
Incredible houses out there.
Huh?
See all those ones that burned down like the dude from a back to the future.
The old guy,
those professors.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
His house burnt down.
That sucks.
Yeah.
They had these giant mansions out there and the fires just cut through a whole
neighborhood.
That's crazy shit.
When you realized that fire can do that and there's three colleges out there.
Yeah,
there's quite a few.
there's like three topping colleges.
One of them had like the highest rate of stds of any college in the country.
So you know,
the rate of stds have any in the country.
Wow.
So you know the party,
it's warm out.
It's one people fuck more probably.
Right.
She's an outside college.
Remember when you were in college,
you're just like,
just tapping ass left and right.
And you're like,
it's always going to be like this.
At some point you're like,
oh,
I didn't go away for college.
I went to a college in Boston so that I could still train and compete martial
arts tournaments.
So I stayed for the first couple of years.
I was at home still until I was 20.
When I was 20 I moved out.
And when,
uh,
I would,
go to school.
I would just go to school for the day and then leave.
I had no like,
school interaction I had no,
I didn't go to parties.
I didn't get laid in college at all.
College was the high school.
Yes.
But college is a biggest drought of bisexual career ever.
Really?
Yeah.
Also the most insecure in college too because then it was,
I was um,
making this transition from being this person who concentrated on only martial
arts my entire life.
Literally barely paid attention to school.
So all of a sudden,
you know,
becoming like 18,
19 out in the real world and going,
how the fuck am I gonna support myself.
You know,
I was teaching taekwondo at Boston University and I had my own school in revere,
but I was like,
what am I going to do man?
I just do this for the rest of my life because this is not really what I want to
do.
I want to compete,
but there's no money in competing and then,
and then you start thinking about brain damage,
all sorts of other things.
And I was like,
God damn,
I might become a loser,
you know,
I had no definitive direction until I went into stand up.
I was just competing and then worrying about shit.
From the time I was like 19,
I had started to realize like maybe this was like a dead end route.
Like where am I going with this?
Because I also,
when I was 19 I had some.
I've seen some of the worst knockouts
around that age.
I'd seen some bad head kick knockouts where I was like,
Whoa,
like what made you know what if that happens,
I may go,
go flat line,
dude.
I saw a lot of guys get kicked in the head man.
A lot of guys get like seriously flatlined,
like just like that dude in the subway where the guy sucker punches him.
I've seen a lot of that.
When you get kicked,
like taekwondo kicks to the head.
They don't land that often,
but man,
when they land it's like getting hit with a bat.
There was a video on this website that's really cool.
Called Barstool sports.com and they like it just a fun sports website and they
showed these guys mma fighting in their living room and the w,
you know,
the first time they fight,
the one guy tapped,
the second one,
dude,
they're fighting in living.
Do just head kicks him.
The guy just goes down,
hits his head basically on like the marble of the fireplace and like lights out.
Oh God.
See I didn't get late in high school,
but then I went to college and it was just insanity.
Sure.
If I went to a college,
if I had actually gone away,
so I went to unl.
Oh,
Jesus just didn't even pretend you're going to learn anything and I didn't.
Did I admit it?
I moved there.
I wanted to do stand up as a lot of drugs.
I know,
you know,
I didn't really get into anything like that until later.
Much is vegas as a real drug problem.
Right.
There's different vegas man.
Sounds crazy.
Like it was like,
you know how there was the modern,
the news,
the mob vegas.
Yeah.
I was out there kind of during the,
during the,
uh,
family friendly vegas that happened for a little while.
Right?
Yeah.
And then when I left and it became mma,
you know,
Terrordome Vegas,
that is just,
you know,
where they're like,
screw it,
we're just the party destination.
And they,
how do they,
how do you think they made that decision?
You were living there.
The family wasn't making as much money.
That's what it was.
Now this one color Fred's name.
You'd have a joke about,
you know,
you don't take a hooker to Disneyland.
It's just like,
why would you make Vegas a family destination?
Yeah.
It was just a place where it's,
you know,
it was just what's there for the kids.
Yeah.
Well,
at one point there was a treasurer,
a like a circus circus had this huge like park and then the mgm grand tried to
create a park.
It just like,
you're not going to bring your kids where there's gambling.
It sounds like a good idea.
People do all the time,
but not like what they wrote.
They were hoping to pull from Orlando,
Orlando,
let's go to vegas and just.
It's never gonna happen,
man.
It's interesting when a bunch of different metamorphoses have gone on,
you know,
and now it's Kinda like it's in a different place.
Like Vegas is broke.
Is that what it is now?
Dead.
It's just definitely have lost a lot.
Well they sit down like 50 percent men,
50 percent and there's all those shopping centers that they started to build and
then whatever happened and now they're just sitting there.
Yeah,
there's a few of those.
Weird.
Where's it in Saudi Arabia?
They have that too or yeah,
a huge bill and that money's gone.
Stop that.
It's so weird that the same amount of people can exist.
The same
amount of metals,
Sam Lao steel,
same amount of minerals.
Same amount of resources and yet somehow or another there's no money anymore.
It's so strange.
It's like,
well,
you know,
a.
everybody was under an illusion before.
Well,
can,
can you trick me again please?
Yeah.
We tricked the world again and keep this rolling.
It's like,
where does the,
like,
where's the money?
It's,
there was money to make money are way too stupid for this conversation.
You know what it is?
I was like,
where's the beef commercial?
Where's the money?
It's rich people hoarding.
That's what's going on.
Rich people hoarding everything.
Friday night comedy Magic Club in Hermosa Beach.
It will sell out.
Trust me,
Duncan trussell's with me.
And um,
I don't know who else is going to come with me,
but somebody else too.
I try to get Tripoli.
I wouldn't do.
We haven't gigged together in a while.
I started doing some gigs together.
You know what I'm doing?
San Jose with Dhea is why don't you come along,
want to do this,
tell me why not?
That's the next weekend.
The next following Friday.
So they're done now.
The UFC vendelay Silva versus Kang Lee
shogun versus Henderson when they are doing.
I don't know what I did in a past life dude,
but I hooked it up.
You did this job December first.
December first.
Now convinced me I can't come.
You can't.
I can't come.
Brian,
work on it.
Brian.
I figure on the good things with the new podcast place.
You gotta start working on the business side.
We talked about that and we'll keep talking about that.
You know Brian's podcast,
death squad.
For anybody who wants to sponsor it.
We were talking to the fleshlight.
Hopefully they'll come through with it,
but Brian's got A.
I mean it's always in the top 20 of itunes comedy.
There's a bunch of funny Comic Sans Aaa has a show on called the naughty show.
There's a Thompson Gaura and his wife,
Mrs Laura.
They have a show called your mom's house.
The whole lineup is great.
There's no bad one run in Washington and now has one called the bone zone.
I liked that name and it.
What it is is free.
Okay.
It's free podcasts and you know,
if you look up for some shit to listen to at work and by the way,
all the people that I saw in England weekend,
thank you very much.
That was what a fucking awesome,
polite crowd and 90 percent of them are like podcast fans.
It was cool as fuck dude.
One guy had a a t shirt on.
So my protons,
I like existed in pre big bang conditions.
Anybody wants to change that?
You got to come through me.
He had a tee shirt on without written out.
It was dope.
And then another guy had a desk wide,
a lineup,
tee-shirt reservoir,
reservoir dogs with all of our faces.
It was really dope.
Hey,
have you ever thought about.
I was telling a Red Bandana that he should take that thing that turned into a t
shirt and try to sell it to make money for the desk water,
something like that where we're going to definitely know we did this.
Uh,
this thing.
I'm going to talk to this guy.
Um,
how cool is that?
If you don't always talking about there's a gentleman,
what's his name?
What's the guy's name?
It's a caught me on God,
something sweatpants or something like that.
Casual sweatpants.com.
I think it is that his name.
But anyway,
he made this cool thing,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast and it's all these uh,
animated pictures of like Kevin Smith and Ari Shaffir.
I'm excited about Sam Aaa Zombie like me and Joey is,
and you know,
everybody's in it.
It's,
it's Dunkin's in it.
It's really fucking awesome at and an honor.
And that's one of the coolest things about this podcast is this community that
it's sort of brought together and that's not something we take lightly at all.
You know,
I'm,
I'm amazed and I'm honored by it all and it's a,
it's kind of humbling and I don't,
I never know what to say.
I'll click on some link and someone will say something I made for your podcast
and I'll click it on Lincoln.
It's just awesome.
Inspirational rant to tied to music and you know,
you listened to it and you're like,
well that's why you can't interrupt the rants broke because they'll,
they'll take those.
So you've got to be careful.
What I do now as a kid for foremost sweatpants is the name of my podcast where I
call red bands rant and we do it a half an hour in the podcast where he can talk
about whatever he wants because he always will be jamming and all of a sudden
it'd be like left turn out of nowhere.
We're like,
what was.
Sometimes that's okay,
but you got to let people rent when they were in the middle of a rain.
Can't stop it because then the stop one of these cool videos that gets made.
Guys have animated them.
We've got a couple of guys have animated them.
It's fucking awesome.
And Kevin Pereira from the tech of the show.
He's got a wee.
He wants to figure out a way to animate it with his production company.
So we do that.
Yeah,
because there's so many times people have told crazy fucking stories and those
stories can make awesome animated little clips.
You just have to have someone sit through the 10,000 hours of,
you know,
we got to.
This was like 1:50,
two was this number with numbers.
I think it's like 1:54.
Is it really?
One hundred 54 podcasts.
Each one of them is at least two hours and some of them are more so.
What's the longest one?
Kevin Smith.
That was like three and a half hours I think.
Something like that.
Anyway,
bitches.
This show is basically over.
Let's wrap it up.
Let's bring it on home.
Brought to you by the fleshlight.
Sam triple got his own today.
Boy,
hours from now,
Sam Aaa will be shooting loads into that thing.
You will have the most thunderous orgasms.
You'd be shocked at.
How much does it come with how the cleanup?
I've never cleaned it the jain and getting their soap.
Water fingers.
Don't.
Don't be scared.
Home [inaudible] dot com.
Thank you to the flashlight and go to jail.
You don't have to start that bitch so soon.
We've got a lot to talk about.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the codename Rogan,
you will get 15 percent off the number one sex toys for men and we're also
brought to you by Alpha brain from onnit.com.
I get a couple of those too.
I got it for you too.
Dude.
I got the new mood on a dotcom o n n I t we have a bunch of different
supplements that we are currently offering for sale.
Some of them are for athletic performance,
some of them referral,
mental performance.
A new mood is an htp enhancement or a software that enhances your mood.
And uh,
that's the Neal Brennan Shit that he's the one that told me about that.
But uh,
go to Joe Rogan.net and click on the link and enter in the code name Rogan,
and you will get 10 percent off of that as well.
And if you don't want it,
don't buy it.
Don't complain.
One hundred percent money back guarantee.
One hundred percent money guarantee.
If you think it's too expensive,
please don't buy it.
Please take the ingredients.
Go buys the stuff,
can save some money,
we should save some money and just tell me.
I hope it works.
I hope it works where it works for me.
That's the only reason why I'm selling it.
Period.
End of discussion.
Anyway.
I'm to go in advanced white by Armand heroin.
You know,
this is my truth.
Grace.
I'm not promoting this toothpaste.
This is a lot of shit that we see too.
The best coconut water in the world.
They don't pay us,
but it's fucking stuff is awesome.
From Thailand.
That's the key folks.
You've got to get a coconut water from Thailand.
I've had some coconut water tastes like dish water,
so people still like,
dude,
why do you guys drink coconut water in the podcast?
Like so gross.
Some of it's gross.
I agree with you,
but this oh shit is fucking
sweet and delicious.
It makes me pee.
Well that shouldn't get a confidence on people soon about the sponsor.
Yeah,
whatever.
Either way.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I like stuff because it's good and see two,
I was fucking delicious.
Uh,
that's it.
Tomorrow.
Dave attell with joins the podcast at three PM.
Yeah.
And then Thursday Duncan trussell.
So we've got a party going on this week folks.
And uh,
we're also probably going to do a show at the ice house where the new desk squad
studio is located at the Ice House in Pasadena.
And that's probably going to be going down on Thursday.
We'll give you some more information about that tomorrow.
So that is the end of this program.
Cue The music sun.
Hey,
Joe Rogan podcast.
Thank you all.
Thank you.
And again,
thank you for tuning in continuously.
Thank you.
Thank you for letting us be a part of your world.
We appreciate it.
Please follow Sam triply on twitter.
Sam T R I,
p o l I triple e,
Sam,
Tripoli,
my here,
my brother follow red band as well.
And don't forget to subscribe to the death squad on Itunes,
the aforementioned podcast,
and we will be podcasting if we do it Thursday night,
we will do a live at the ice house,
which will be one of our new podcasts that we will be offering.
We will not stop until you're sick of us.
Like I'm sick of Kim Kardashian.
God bless everybody.
Piece and chicken grease.
We love you bitches.